Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 37.
Wir haben uns entschieden, dass wir dieses Mal eine Stammtischfolge machen. Nicht im Sinne von wir pögeln einfach nur rum, sondern im Sinne von da haben sich einige Sachen angesammelt, bevor wir das letzte Mal die Gelegenheit hatten, einfach wild mehrere Themen pro Sendung zu besprechen. Und da haben wir uns entschieden, dass wir das einfach diesmal machen.
Genau, weil wie ihr vielleicht auch schon bemerkt habt, ist dieses Jahr so ein bisschen anders als die anderen Jahre. Die Merkwürdigkeiten und die Weirdness in der Welt scheinen nicht so richtig aufzuhören. Das heißt, dass wir sehen immer mehr Nachrichten, Abfolgen, wo man sich immer so denkt, naja, wenn man sowas irgendwie in so einen Roman schreiben würde, dann bekäme man die Passage vom Lektor zurück mit der Bemerkung, dass völlig unrealistisch glaubt auch sowieso niemand. Und das stimmt auch. Tatsächlich stimmt das auch so. Eigentlich weiß man nicht mehr so richtig, ob man überhaupt noch irgendwas glauben kann, was einem da präsentiert wird. Beziehungsweise sind die Verbindungen, die sich dann da so andeuten, wie jetzt gerade die Tage kam ja diese Meldung mit der Verbindung der DNA von einem von den NSU-Terroristen zu einem Kindermord, der eine Weile vorher stattfand. Und da gibt es dann so zwei Möglichkeiten. Eines ist es halt irgendein bizarrer Fehler. So ähnlich wie halt das Phantom von Heilbronn, wo damals eine Mitarbeiterin in der Verpackung von diesen DNA-Wattestäbchen da gelegentlich ihre DNA hinterlassen hat. Und die sollten ja eigentlich DNA-Spuren frei sein. Waren es aber nicht. Die waren nur sterile, aber nicht DNA-Spuren frei. Und deren DNA wurde dann in allen möglichen Tatorten gefunden. Und das sah schon irgendwie alles ganz schön wild aus. Aber war es dann halt doch nicht so wild, nachdem es rauskam. Aber da hat sich ja gerade der BKA-Direktor doch relativ eindeutig geäußert und gemeint, ne, ne, da seien sie sich dieses Mal sicher, dass es keine Cross-Kontamination sein könnte, sondern dass die Spur wahrscheinlich schon echt sei.
Und zwar weil verschiedene Institute beteiligt waren.
War die Untersuchung nicht im selben Institut?
Ne, also das war irgendwie, was ich gelesen hatte, ich glaube in der Süddeutschen, dass von peggy und von den NSU-Geschichten, also dass in dem Institut, was die peggy DNA geprüft hat, überhaupt keine Probe von dem Reinhardt, wie es der Böhne hat gewesen sein kann, weil das ein anderes Institut war. Das war irgendwie, was ich, aber das ist jetzt auch schon wieder an einem halben Tag her insofern.
Okay, das soll ich vielleicht noch mal raussuchen. Na jedenfalls, was mir halt dann sofort einfiel, war eine Geschichte, die wir, glaube ich, schon ein oder zwei in Sendungen erwähnt hatten, nämlich die so genannten Brabandkillers. Eine sehr mysteriöse Gruppe von Leuten, die höchst brutale Überfälle gemacht haben in Belgien. Und dabei halt immer wieder jede Menge Leute umgelegt haben, bei irgendwelchen Supermarkt-Überfällen. Und dann stellte sich dann immer raus, dass dann irgendwie zufällig gab es dann so zwei oder drei Leute, die dabei umgekommen sind, deren Bedeutung für irgendwie andere Geschichten unter anderem halt irgendwie diese üblichen belgischen Skandale da dann erst später klar wurde. Und dieser Zusammenhang von irgendwie so Gladius, slash Terrorismus, Naziteorismus zu Kindesmissbrauchsnetzwerken ist nie so richtig aufgeklärt worden in diesem Fall. Da gab es halt immer wieder Hinweise und mögliche Spuren, aber nie so die ganz klaren Details. Aber das war so das erste, was mir da einfiel. So zumal ja halt irgendwie die Deckung der NSU durch irgendwie verschiedene Behörden, ob jetzt so ein individueller Mitarbeiter oder systematisch sich eine Zwecke in diesen Behörden in Deutschland schon ja irgendeinen Grund gehabt haben muss. Das machen die im Zweifel nicht aus Freizeitsport oder weil sie halt irgendwie da so ein paar Naziteoristen sympathisch finden. Und von daher finde ich diesen Zusammenhang jetzt zu Fällen von Kindesmissbrauch schon einigermaßen interessant. Also keine Ahnung, was da jetzt rauskommt, aber es wäre jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass halt irgendwie so eine Naziteororganisation mit Kindesmissbrauch in Verbindung steht oder mit Erpressungen durch sowas oder ähnliche Dinge.
Aber was auch an dem Fall ganz lustig ist, ist, dass es dann so, naja, ich weiß, man weiß nie, ob es Zufälle sind oder nicht, aber es gibt halt so Sachen, die auffallen, wie zum Beispiel, dass der Chef-Ermittler derselbe war in beiden Fällen und in beiden Fällen hat er im Grunde grob falsch sich erst auf irgendein Ziel festgelegt, was er gerne herausfinden will, nämlich bei peggy war das, was war bei peggy dieses Ziel? Ich glaube, irgendwie hat er in Richtung von einem geistig behinderten, was war das, ein Typ jedenfalls, hat sich da relativ früh festgelegt. Und das muss gar nicht Absicht sein, aber wenn man einmal anfängt, sich so vorher schon festzulegen, dann gibt es einen Bias, dass man eben Sachen viel wichtiger erachtet, die das bestätigen, als Sachen, die es widerlegen.
Aber so ist ja unser Gehirn gebaut. Also wir sind ja gewonnen.
Genau, also ich würde gar nicht sagen, der ist irgendwie böse und hat jetzt irgendwie, ja, der wollte da wahrscheinlich, hat er nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen, wie man so schön sagt, in der Bundesregierung gearbeitet. Aber der hat halt beide mal irgendwie ins Blaue geforscht. Und in beiden Fällen ist er ja erst gefeiert worden als der großartige.
Weil er Lösungen gebracht hat.
Weil er Lösungen gebracht hat, genau. Und das gesamte System hat im Grunde versagt und nicht gemerkt, dass das falsch war. Ja, das finde ich immer spannend. Man ist jetzt einfach auf irgendeinen Typen zu zeigen. Ja, aber es ist ja nicht nur er, der in allen Fällen sozusagen derselbe war, sondern es gab dann auch irgendeinen berühmten Profiler, den die eingeschaltet haben in beiden Fällen und der auch die falschen Hypothesen gestützt hat. Und dann gibt es da wohl noch irgendwelche Überlappungen bei den Gutachtern, allerdings nicht zwischen den beiden Fällen, sondern peggy und der Fall Mollert, der ja auch ein krasser Justizfehler war. Und da fragt man sich, ist jetzt unsere Szene einfach so klein in Deutschland, dass da immer die drei Leute sich gegenseitig immer in den Weg laufen? Oder ist es so ein Cluster von Leuten, die jetzt halt irgendwie eine Häufung von schlechten Fällen haben? Sieht es bei den anderen anders aus? Das sind so Fragen, die sich da stellen.
Na, ich glaube, dass es schon eine Rolle spielt, dass der Druck, Lösungen zu präsentieren, insbesondere auch durch Boulevard-Medien, aber eben auch durch Facebook, relativ groß ist. Also das halt so, gerade so Verbrechen gegen Kinder. Da steht die Polizei unter einem enormen Handlungsdruck, dass sie da halt irgendwie Lösungen bzw. Ermittlungsergebnisse präsentiert, dass klar ist, wer jetzt der Täter ist, dass es halt irgendwie Möglichkeiten gibt, das Gefühl zu haben, da wäre jetzt irgendwie Gerechtigkeit geschehen. Und ich glaube, dieser Druck führt dann durchaus natürlich auch dazu, dass eher etwas vorschneller Schlüsse gezogen werden. Da gab es ja ein paar solche Fälle in den letzten Jahren, wo klar war, dass die, also am Hinterher dann natürlich erst klar war, dass Geständnisse halt irgendwie nicht richtig waren oder dass die Spurenlagen sehr selektiv interpretiert wurden oder dass halt irgendwie bestimmte Hinweise einfach total ignoriert wurden. Also halt gerade Hinweise aus der Bevölkerung, gerade dieser Fall peggy, als ich gerade noch mal so die Pressecoverage davon las, da gibt es halt eine Menge so Hinweise, wo man sich dann fragt, ok, warum sind die denn eigentlich nachgegangen? Und natürlich gibt es dann wieder Antworten darauf, die da halt lauten, ok, wenn du halt irgendwie ein paar tausend solche Hinweise und Spuren hast, dann ist es halt sehr schwer rauszubekommen, welche jetzt diejenigen sind, die wirklich stichhaltig sind, beziehungsweise dich halt einer Lösung des Falls näherbringen. Und also gerade Kriminalistik ist ja insofern ein bisschen anders als der Trend in der momentanen Wissenschaft, der weggeht von Kausalketten hin zu nur reiner Korrelationsbetrachtung. Das ist ja so der Megatrend, den wir gerade haben, wo wir zu viele Daten haben können, wo wir jetzt Koalitionen finden, auch wenn es eigentlich keinen Kausalzusammenhang gibt. Da gibt es diese schöne Webseite.
Spurious Correlation Sanding.
Genau, die müssen wir mal wieder verlinken.
Ja, aber das ist ein Trend, den wir häufiger sehen können, dass Druck auf Behörden ausgeübt wird und dass dann Scheiße rauskommt. Mir fällt jetzt ein, wir hatten jetzt gerade den Fall mit CETA. Da gibt es jetzt in der Wallonie, das ist der französischsprachige Teil der von Belgien, eigentlich eher so landwirtschaftlich dominiert. Da gibt es Widerstand gegen CETA. Das ist TTIP-Äquivalent mit Kanada statt den USA. Und da gab es auch gewaltigen Druck auf die Politik von den Bundespolitikern. Und das ist häufig, wenn man irgendwie Postmortem-Analysen von irgendwelchen massiv verkackten Sachen macht, dann findet man raus, da gab es einfach Druck. Und irgendwann haben die Leute keinen Bock mehr gehabt und haben nachgegeben. Und daraus entstehen dann schlechte Sachen im Allgemeinen. Also da könnte man eigentlich auch mal generell nachsuchen, wo wird hier gerade massiv Druck gemacht? Ist das nicht an sich schon ein Indikator dafür, dass irgendwas schief läuft? Denn wenn das inhaltlich überzeugend wäre, dann bräuchte man ja den Druck nicht. Den braucht man ja nur, wenn man eigentlich keine Argumente hat, sondern Leute aus dem Weg haben will, die, bevor sie selbstständig zu einem Ergebnis kommen, was möglicherweise der gewünschten Sache widerspricht.
Ich glaube ja, dass da so eine gewisse... Also dieser Druck ist ja häufiger mal, das hat man ja auch irgendwie so in der Wirtschaft und so, häufiger ist es ja so, dass das Argument ist so, ja verkünstelt euch hier mal nicht, oder nehmt doch mal eine Lösung, die halt irgendwie schneller und kürzer ist, oder so genau brauchen wir es doch gar nicht, das Ergebnis, oder so präzise wollen wir es eigentlich gar nicht wissen, weil wir brauchen nur eine ungefähre Lösung, damit wir irgendwie unsere Strategie weiter planen können oder so.
Gerne gepaart mit, das wird hier alles zu teuer, wenn wir jetzt in der Untersuchung.
Wenn wir jetzt halt irgendwie tatsächlich irgendwie es halt bis zu Ende erforschen, wird es halt zu teuer, was ja häufiger auch mal stimmt. Also man muss sich ja schon überlegen, wo setzt man halt seine Energien, seine Ressourcen ein? Und ich glaube aber, dass es halt auch eine Menge damit zu tun hat, dass das Wissen darum, wie statistische Analysen, wie Zusammenhangsanalysen wirklich funktionieren und wie die Ergebnisse daraus zu interpretieren sind, das abnimmt.
Ja, da gibt es in einiger Zeit Indizien für. Also ich glaube, dass das eine Ökonomisierung der Forschung ist, dass wir jetzt anfangen sozusagen Geldgegenwert und Papers miteinander zu verrechnen und sagen, wenn du pro Paper irgendwie mehr Kohle verbrauchst als der andere Typ, dann investieren wir lieber bei dem, denn die Uni wird danach bemessen, wie viele Papers hier produziert werden. So irgendwie so eine Art Zusammenhang scheint es dazu zu geben. Ich bin gerade heute über so einen Artikel gestolpert, der genau in die Richtung ging, in den Sozialwissenschaften, so psychologische und soziologische Experimente. Und das trifft mich sehr, weil ich mich dafür sehr interessiere. Unter anderem ist es genau das Herz der Bücher von Kahnemann und Chialdini, die wir ja auch schon empfohlen haben. Und da geht es darum, dass es so eine Art Apokalypse gibt unter den Papers. Da hat sich nämlich herausgestellt, dass der Großteil der Mathematik, die da verwendet wird, nicht wirklich verstanden wurde von den Leuten. Ich habe vor einer Weile ein Video gesehen, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das wiederfinden für die Show Notes, das war sehr witzig. Das zentrale Konstrukt für so statistische Auswertung von irgendwelchen Samples, wo dann eben auch Rauschen drin ist, sind P-Values. Und das ist ein Konzept, was einfach viele Leute nicht verstanden haben, weil das auch nicht so einfach ist und weil die Erklärung schon sehr kompliziert klingt. Und es gab mal ein lustiges Video, wo ein Typ auf so eine Veranstaltung von Statistikern, was glaube ich gegangen ist, oder Leute zumindest, die sich genau damit beschäftigt haben, in anderer Leute Papers irgendwie P-Value-Fehler zu finden und hat die einfach so Gonzo-mäßig mit Mikrofonen hingehalten, so definier uns doch mal, was ein P-Value eigentlich ist. Und das konnte fast keiner definieren. Das heißt, so das Basisinstrument, das statistische Basisinstrument, was den gesamten Forschungsergebnissen im Grunde zugrunde liegt, ist von den Leuten nicht gut verstanden worden. Und das führt dazu, dass bei genauer Betrachtung wohl ein Großteil der Papers der letzten 40 Jahre zumindest partiell Unsinn sind. Ja, Ergebnisse lassen sich nicht reproduzieren. Wenn man noch mal nachrechnet, bei einigen sogar, kommen andere Werte raus. Also es klingt wie ein ziemlicher Totalschaden. Und ich glaube, dass das nur der erste Bereich ist, in dem das mal jemandem auffällt. Weil Statistik ist so eine Sache, die müssen viele mitbelegen für ihr Studium. Aber das wird eher so stiefmütterlich behandelt, so wie das müsste jetzt halt belegen. Du hattest doch auch ein paar Einblicke, die du vielleicht mal erläutern kannst an der Stelle.
Naja, also ich glaube, dass ein Teil der Probleme daraus resultiert, dass in der Ausbildung an den Universitäten, die insbesondere Statistikmodule seit vielen Jahren nicht angefasst wurden. Also die sind halt bei allen Studenten, außer ganz wenigen, die da halt irgendwie einen Fairway für haben, ziemlich verhasst. So das sind halt immer so die, wo alle sich irgendwie so ein bisschen verdrücken und dann irgendwie total froh sind, durchgekommen zu sein. Also den so, wo halt klar ist, okay, das ist jetzt nicht das, was irgendwie da man's Talent entspricht. So und da kriegt man dann halt R beigebracht, was halt also typischerweise in der deutschen Uni ist, was halt so ein Software ist. Genau, was so ein Softwarepaket ist für halt so statistische Analysen. Und mir scheint, dass ein guter Teil dessen, was da den Leuten beigebracht wird, darin besteht, wie man halt so Ergebnismassagen richtig macht. Also gerade die Laborexperimente, die sie dann mal auswerten müssen und so, je nach Wissenschaft, in der sie sind, sind halt dann natürlich irgendwie mit groben Rauschen unterlegt und irgendwie oder funktionieren halt auch mal nicht, so wie im normalen Alltag auch. Aber die Incentivierung, dann trotzdem halt ein signifikantes Ergebnis zu erzielen, ist halt irgendwie relativ groß.
Na und man kriegt auch die Faktoren nicht alle rausgerechnet, weil die möglicherweise nicht alle bekannt sind, die irgendwelche Einflüsse haben. Genau. Es ist halt alles nicht so einfach in der Praxis. Und jetzt, was eins dieser Ergebnisse, das ist ja nicht nur die P-Value-Geschichte, die da ein Problem ist, sondern eins der Probleme ist, dass der Experiment-Durchführer selbst schon einen Einfluss ausüben kann auf die Validität des Ergebnisses, dadurch, dass er eben bestimmte Sachen selektiert, die nicht selektiert werden sollen, und zwar unterbewusst. Also wir reden jetzt gar nicht mal von irgendwie, ich will das hier kaputt machen, oder ich habe hier meinen Wert vorher festgelegt, was es auch gibt und was immer wieder ein Skandal ist, aber es kann eben auch sein, dass das unterbewusst passiert, dass man sich sein Experiment kaputt macht, ohne es zu merken. Und ich habe jetzt Soziologie und Psychologie angesprochen, aber diese P-Value-Geschichten, die spielen auch eine Rolle in Criminal Justice and Criminology, also das sind auch die Theorie, die dem Strafrecht unterliegt, wird damit behandelt. Und damit haben wir einen schönen Zirkelschluss. Naja, die machen auch so, es geht immer, wenn du eine Nullhypothese hast und einen Datensatz und dann eben darauf umrechnest, dass es einfach eine Sache, die da auch angewendet wird. Das heißt, die Kriminalwissenschaften untersuchen ja auch so soziologische Zusammenhänge gelegentlich. Und da ist halt die Frage, wie viel da jetzt da gemacht werden muss. Das weiß man halt alles nicht. Aber also dieses Ding, was ich da gelesen hab, war von einem Typen, der sozusagen die Hypothese vertritt, dass man jetzt mal die gesamten Papers alle noch mal neu evaluieren muss. Und dass der Aufhänger für diesen Artikel war ein offener Brief von, oh, ich krieg das jetzt hier nicht nicht richtig zusammen, irgendwie die Vorsitzende einer American Society auf irgendwas, also einen Fachzusammenschluss oder irgendwie so ein Journalzusammenschluss oder so. Jedenfalls die hat sich geäußert und fühlte sich also persönlich angegriffen und beklagte sich über den Stil von diesen Kritiken an existierenden Forschungsergebnissen, weil unter anderem die auf sozialen Medien verteilt würden, anstatt dass man sozusagen diskret dem Forschungstreibenden mitteilt, dass er Mist gemacht hat. Und das ist also sozusagen eine Parallele zu einer Sache, die wir ja auch schon hatten. Missponsible disclosure bei Sicherheitslücken ist im Grunde dieselbe Problematik. Natürlich ist es dem Typ, der das Paper geschrieben hat oder der Forscherin, viel lieber, wenn das irgendwie sich hintenrum irgendwie klären lässt. Man macht vielleicht irgendwie publiziert ein paar Errata, ruft das alte Paper zurück, macht ein neues draus. Das ist ja viel schöner, als wenn es da irgendeinen Shitstorm auf Twitter gibt. Das ist ja völlig klar. Aber der Typ fängt dann halt an und verteidigt das und findet, das ist ein strukturelles Problem in der Forschung. Und da müssen wir uns mit auseinandersetzen und guckt dann, was ich ja sehr fies finde, aber was natürlich ein schöner Lacher ist. An der Stelle sich auch die Papers an, die diese Frau so veröffentlicht hat und findet da also auch kritikwürdige Punkte, um es mal schwarz zu formulieren. Und das scheint wirklich ein großes Problem im gesamten Forschungsbereich zu sein. Wie groß das ist, keine Ahnung, aber es liest sich schlimm. Und wir haben gerade bei Kriminologie, haben wir häufig so Ergebnisse gehabt in den letzten Jahren, wo sich Sachen als Junk-Science rausgestellt haben, besonders aus dem FBI-Umfeld.
Bestimmt ja, die Spuren.
Der Reihe nach sind ihre Sachen da weggebrochen. Also ich erinnere mich daran, dass es ein DNA-Labor gab, woraus kam, dass die eine Forscherin einfach immer, sozusagen gar nicht versucht hat, ergebnisoffen irgendwelche Sachen zu prüfen, sondern die hat sozusagen den, ach der ist schuldig, naja, da finde ich jetzt mal einen Beweis für. Und dann mussten hunderte von Fällen aufgerollt werden. Teilweise sind die Leute hingerichtet worden in der Zwischenzeit. Also ganz furchtbar. Ja, dann das neueste war die Gesichtserkennung vom FBI. Bullshit. Und dann gab es auch mal was mit Fingerabdrücken, glaube ich meintest du, aber das habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden. Aber also das ist ein durchziehender Faktor bei diesen gesamten kriminologischen Sachen. Auch die Fingerabdrücke ganz am Anfang haben viel zu wenig Minuzier gehabt. Das sind so die Merkmale, die man extrahiert aus einem Fingerabdruck um so zu sagen.
Das ist halt so, wenn man so einen Fingerabdruck anguckt, dann hat man Linien, die enden und Linien, die sich verzweigen. Das sind die so lang Minuzier.
Und die extrahiert man.
Das sind halt die Punkte, nach denen man sucht. Und deren Position relativ zueinander ist das, was so einen Fingerabdruck ausmacht. Also quasi die Daten, die auch so einen Fingerabdruckscanner zum Beispiel liest. Und der bildet dann halt so ein Vektorsystem draussen. Und diese Vektoren, also deren Verhältnis zueinander, ist halt der eigentliche digitale Abbild des Fingerabdrucks.
Und da kam dann raus, also das ist ja nun eine Wissenschaft, die auch schon, weiß nicht, gut hundert Jahre alt ist. Und da kam dann halt raus, dass die am Anfang gedacht haben, zehn Minutien zu extrahieren reicht. Und wenn man ausrechnet, wie viel Menschen man auseinanderhalten kann, dann sind es halt weniger als Großbritannien Einwohner hatte zu der Zeit. Das sind auch ganz triviale Erkenntnisse, dass man sagt, es gibt einfach mehr Menschen, als du Möglichkeiten in deinem Fingerabdruck-Datensatz hast.
Wenn du zu wenig Bits da drin hast.
Ja, und also diese Art von Problem gab es auch, wo man denkt, das muss doch jemandem aufgefallen sein.
In Großbritannien war eigentlich noch deutlich, das war halt irgendwie so was, dass sie am Ende klar war, dass es bei irgendwie so was wie sechs Millionen Leuten oder so in der Datenbank eine Collision geben musste.
Ja, also genau diese Art von Problemen. Und das sind auch Sachen, wo man sagen kann, okay, also wer Matheunterricht aufgepasst hat, dem hätte das eigentlich auffallen müssen. Ja, aber so ist es eben nicht. Mathe ist schwierig. Und wer Krimiologie studiert, hat vielleicht vorher in Mathe nicht so die Glanznoten gehabt. Ich übertreibe jetzt natürlich. Aber als ich vielleicht gedacht, ich studiere Krimiologie, um nicht Mathe machen zu müssen, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ich glaube ja tatsächlich, dass es auch mit der Art und Weise, wie es gelehrt wird, zu tun hat. Also von uns angucken, dass man so was ja auch durchaus unterhaltsam und einprägsam lernen kann. Und also wenn man zum Beispiel so mal die Bücher von Nate Silver liest, ist so eine Statistik aus den USA, der ist immer, also sein wichtigstes Buch war The Signal and the Noise, der genau diese Probleme sehr ausführlich behandelt. Lohnt auf jeden Fall noch mal zu lesen. Und der macht auch gerade sehr unterhaltsame Sachen zu den amerikanischen Wahlen. Also der macht Analysen von Umfragen. Und ist da halt so fies, dass er die Qualität der Umfragen, also der Umfrageinstitute mal rated. Und die dann halt wiederum in seine Modelle einfließen lässt. Also dann sagst du, naja, die rufen sowieso nur Vormittags auf Festungsanschlüssen an. Und wenn sie dann halt mal...
Jetzt krieg ich mal die Hausfragen dran, ja?
Na ja, und dann müssen sie natürlich irgendwie das Gewichten, dass es halt irgendwie wieder passt mit der Demografie. Und dann haben sie irgendwie noch zwei oder drei Leute dabei, die ja dann ihre Nischendemografie repräsentieren. Da gab es gerade diese Geschichte.
Da ging es um einen einzelnen 19-jährigen Schwarzen aus, ich glaube Illinois oder so, der eben Trump-Supporter ist. Und weil seine Demografiegruppe so unterrepräsentiert ist in Umfragen, weil die einfach alle andere Sachen zu tun haben, als bei irgendwelchen Bullshit-Umfragen teilzunehmen, hat seine Stimme so viel Gewicht, dass er sozusagen eigenhändig Parteien-Siege oder Niederlagen prädizieren kann, wenn er sich halt umentscheidet, ob er jetzt doch lieber Hillary gut findet oder Trump.
Also in den Umfragen wohl machen.
In den Umfragen natürlich, nicht in der tatsächlichen Wahl. Aber also das Gerüst, auf dem wir da bauen, ist halt eher sandig.
Also was wir hier sehen, ist dieser Zerfall der Realität. Also dieses nicht mehr eine Konsensrealität haben, sondern halt irgendwie verschiedene Realitäten hat, glaube ich, auch eine Menge damit zu tun. Dass also eine Menge, was uns als Wissenschaft präsentiert wird, stellt sich bei näherer Betrachtung als eher so, naja, oder zumindest nicht hinreichend gut belegt, um darauf zum Beispiel Politik zu bauen. Das ist ja durchaus nicht selten.
Also warte mal, das finde ich aber schwierig, weil Politik ist ja gerade die Sache, die du machst, wenn du nicht weißt, wenn nicht klar ist, was du machen musst. Also den Schritt würde ich jetzt nicht gehen wollen, zu sagen Politik kannst du nur machen, wenn du alles gut verstanden hast.
Nicht nur, aber Politik gibt zunehmend vor, dass die Dinge auf Basis von Verkennung gemacht werden.
Also ich finde das so ein bisschen zweigespalten. Auf der einen Seite gibt es diesen Effekt, dass man das Gefühl hat, ich lebe hier zwar mit Leuten zusammen, mit denen ich immer dachte, ein Wertegerüst zu teilen, dass wir von denselben Annahmen ausgehen im groben, also jetzt nicht in jeder Einzelheit, aber so im groben, und dann bricht es plötzlich weg. Und auf der anderen Seite aber auch Leute, die sich plötzlich mit so einer Disruption, würde man das nennen im Start-up-Speak, dass man sagt, irgendwie das Geschäftsmodell wird disrupted. Die Annahmen stimmen plötzlich nicht mehr. Dass die Leute eben sehr auch Schwierigkeiten haben, damit umzugehen, wenn sie das irgendwo beobachten. Und viele von diesen Leuten, die ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen als Voodoo verunglimpft habe, das ist ja nicht so, dass die das absichtlich gemacht haben. Dass die irgendwie gesagt haben, ich setze jetzt 20 Jahre meines Lebens in den Sand, indem ich Papers produziere, die alle sich als Bullshit draufstellen. Sondern die haben natürlich an ihre Annahmen geglaubt. Und viele von denen haben auch wirklich Probleme. Und auch außerhalb der Forschung haben wirklich Probleme, ihr Fundament anzupassen, wenn sich die Fakten ändern. Das ist eine Sache, die man gut beobachten kann im Moment. Weil ich weiß nicht, ob das nur gefühlt ist, aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass sich viele Fakten gerade ändern. So Sachen, von denen wir ausgegangen sind. Ja, also ich sag mal, gerade so Trump und Hillary sind ein gutes Beispiel, weil einfach viele Leute oder Brexit, ja, viele Leute gucken sich das an und denken so, was denn hier gerade passiert. Weil das so überhaupt nicht mit dem Denkmodell oder dem Wertekostüm in Einklang zu kommen ist. Mit den Erwartungen. Und die stehen einfach nur noch daneben und denken so, ok, das gucke ich mir jetzt mal an. Aber das ist ja genau die falsche Sache. Man muss ja damit umgehen. Man kann nicht nur einfach sagen, oh, das ist ja Popcornunterhaltung. Mal gucken, was als nächstes passiert. So, das reicht ja nicht. Auch die AfD haben wir hier auf der Liste. Das ist auch so eine Sache eigentlich. Was ist denn jetzt los?
Ich glaube ja, dass es nicht nur... Also da gibt es sicher nicht eine Menge Leute, bei denen ist das nicht Absicht. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch eine Menge Leute, bei denen ist das Absicht.
Ja, das gibt es natürlich auch.
Also wir hatten es ja schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, mit Wladislaw Sorkow, einem Berater von Putin, der in Russland quasi diese Putin-Machtübernahme abgesichert hat auf Propagandawiese. Der hat ein paar ganz neue Konzepte in die Politik reingeführt, unter anderem dieses Confusion-Politik. Also was der halt gemacht hat, ist, der hat zum Beispiel in Russland Oppositionsparteien heimlich gefördert, also Oppositionsparteien gegen Putin und das dann öffentlich werden lassen, absichtlich, um einfach die Leute völlig zu verunsichern.
Und dann klammern die sich an das, was sie kennen?
Nee, dann steigen die aus. Also der Effekt ist ja, wenn du das halt nicht mehr verstehst, dann sitzt der selbe Effekt ein, wie wenn du in einer Vorlesung oder Quantenphysik sitzt, dann hörst du so lange zu, bis du noch mitkommst und irgendwann tuned dein Hirn halt raus. Irgendwann denkst du dann halt irgendwie an deinen Einkauf oder deine Waschmaschine oder an irgendwas anderes. Also du kommst halt einfach nicht mehr, also du schaffst es halt einfach nicht mehr. Und genau diesen Effekt zu erzielen.
Hat der absichtlich gemacht.
Adam Curtis hat da so ein kurzes Video, ich glaube, er hat es schon mal verlinkt.
Adam Curtis arbeitet übrigens gerade an seinem nächsten Video, was dann hoffentlich auch außerhalb von iPlayer und BBC zu sehen sein wird, auf irgendwelchen dunklen Kanälen. Ich freue mich da jedenfalls schon drauf. Ich hoffe, ich muss da nicht nach England reisen, um mir Adam Curtis anzusehen.
Ja, ich glaube, es wird schon irgendwo liegen. Also ich will noch mal auf diesen Punkt hin, weil der ist mir gerade sehr wichtig, nämlich diese Confusion-Politik ist, glaube ich, auch genau das, was Trump da macht. Das ist ja halt einfach so ein muddying the water, also dafür sorgen, dass es halt irgendwie keine...
Der wirft so viele Nebelkarzen und Luftballons.
Genau, also der lügt halt schneller, als die Leute Fakt checken können. Und das ist ihm total egal. Also es ist halt auch völlig... Also es tut nicht mal mehr so, als würde die Wahrheit sagen, sondern es ist halt nur noch reine Entertainment und Confusion. Und wozu das halt führt, ist, dass es gibt dagegen halt auch keinen effektiven Konter, außer genau dasselbe zu tun. Also der Wettkampf in den USA gerade bei den Wahlen ist ja, wer schafft es mehr, Leute, die eigentlich für den Gegner stimmen wollten, dazu zu bringen, nicht wählen zu gehen?
Ja.
Also es geht ja nicht mehr darum, Leute zu überzeugen. Hillary macht das noch so ein bisschen so nach dem Motto, irgendwie die negativen Seiten von Trump nach vorne stellen. Ja, aber eben auch sagen, wo für sie noch ist. Und bei Trump ist es halt eigentlich zum großen Teil nur noch, wie scheiße Hillary ist. Und das ändert sich jetzt, also konvergiert jetzt darauf, also jetzt nach der letzten Debatte darauf.
Da hat aber Hillary mit angefangen. Also so leicht würde ich sie ja jetzt nicht wegkommen lassen. Hillarys Wahlkampf war von Anfang an, auch wenn der Trump-Präsident war, dann sind wir alle geliefert.
Nee, die Umstellung hat sie erst ein bisschen später gemacht. Also da war tatsächlich Scott Adams dann mal on the mark. Also ich meine, Scott Adams hat ja sich da irgendwie so ein bisschen arg verritten, irgendwie mit seinem Trump-Liebhaben so. Aber er hat tatsächlich ein paar Mechanismen ganz gut erklärt, nämlich halt diese Persuasion-Nummer, wo er sagt, okay, also das, was gesagt wird, ist halt wesentlich weniger wichtig, als welchen psychologischen Effekt das bei dir hat.
Und so Fakten spielen keine Rolle, ist seine These.
Und Hillary ist ja erst relativ spät, denn also erst so vor zwei oder drei Monaten tatsächlich auf massives Campaigning, was irgendwie nur noch auf das Bauchgefühl zielt, irgendwie umgestiegen. Vorher war sie ja eher so mit längeren Speeches, wo sie erklärt hat, warum halt TTIP gut ist oder was auch immer.
Na, wobei wir jetzt ja das League gesehen haben, dass das ja das Podesta League, was ich ja persönlich ausgebrochen spannend fand mit dem Pied Piper. Die Idee war, also Podesta ist der Wahlkampfmanager von Hillary und ehemaliger Chief of Staff im Weißen Haus, wenn ich das jetzt gar nicht verwechsel. Also eine durchaus wichtige politische Position schon belegt und dessen Mails sind auf WikiLeaks aufgetaucht. Was ja angeblich die Russen gewesen sein sollen, wenn man denen den Ansagen der Amerikaner glauben will. Aber jedenfalls in diesen Mails stehen halt so auch ein paar Sachen drin. So, also viel davon ist einfach uninteressant. Ja, irgendwie ein Risottogericht hat da die Runde gemacht. Aber ein, zwei Mails sind dann doch spannend und da geht es dann darum, als Strategie so die Verrückten aufzupäppeln. Ja, dass man irgendwie, man kann es ja steuern als Wahlkampf, indem man sagt, auf wen reagieren wir denn jetzt schockiert.
Oder auf wen schlagen wir besonders ein oder sowas.
Ja, also sagen wir mal irgendwie Trump und Jeb Bush und was weiß ich, Ted Cruz sagen irgendeinen Bullshit. Ja, dann kann ich ja steuern, wie empört ich auf wen reagiere und damit kann ich transportieren, für wie wichtig ich den als Gegner halte. Und so haben sie einfach Jeb Bush rausgekantet, haben einfach gesagt, ja, Jeb Bush, der macht da mal seinen Kram. Aber was der Trump gesagt hat, ihr gehört was der Trump gesagt hat. Und damit haben sie den Republikanern sozusagen signalisiert, also wenn ihr hier eine Chance haben wollt gegen Hillary, müsst ihr Trump wählen. Und als Strategie ausgerechnet, die kaputtesten Spinner zu nehmen, damit sie dann am Ende einen leichteren Sieg haben, war die Idee. Und das Backfire krank so ein bisschen. Obwohl man weiß es nicht. Also im Moment sieht es ja so aus, als wenn Hillary klar gewinnen wird. Aber als Strategie ist das schon krass, weil die ja im Grunde das Wohl des Landes leichtfertig riskieren in so einer Sache. Also ich meine, wenn die das jetzt nicht werden, dann haben sie sozusagen die Schuld daran, wahrscheinlich nicht die alleinige Schuld, aber sie haben eine Mitschuld daran, dass dieser verrückte da Präsident wird. Ich meine, da würde ich auch nicht ruhig schlafen können. Das ist ja eine Risikoabschätzung, die irgendwann jemand gemacht haben wird bei den Demokraten.
Ich glaube, das war so ein bisschen Verzweiflung, weil die war halt, glaube ich, an irgendeinem Punkt ein bisschen...
Die war echt unpopulierend im Vergleich zu Bernie Sanders vor allem, der plötzlich Inroads gemacht hat, mit denen keiner gerechnet hat.
Und sie war, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen... Also die Kampagne von Hillary war, glaube ich...
Und sie ist ja auch unsympathisch, muss man nicht sagen...
.so ein bisschen verzweifelt darüber, dass Trump halt so viele Leute hinter sich versammeln konnte, obwohl er keine Argumente hat, obwohl er permanent lügt, obwohl er irgendwie nun echt eine merkwürdige Gestalt ist. Und dieses Anti-Establishment-Ding, also diese Anti-Establishment-Stimmung, dass die halt so stark ist, dass die halt schon irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wozu 35 Prozent der Leute in Amiland irgendwie ist, ist halt schon auch jetzt nicht so großes Wunder. Also, ein Freund von mir, der lebt in Kalifornien und mit dem rede ich halt relativ viel darüber, wie so eine Amilandpolitik funktioniert. Und der wies mich jetzt vor ein paar Tagen darauf hin, dass ich mir doch mal den Wahlzettel in Kalifornien angucken soll.
Da musst du jetzt ein bisschen ausholen, was die ganzen Propositions sind.
Ob mir da was auffiel auf diesem Wahlzettel. Und dann scroll ich so über diesen Wahlzettel, dachte ich, es muss ein Druckfehler sein. Aber war kein Druckfehler. Tatsächlich sind da die Kandidaten für Senat und Repräsentantenhaus. Da stehen jeweils zwei Kandidaten auf diesem Wahlzettel und beide sind von den Demokraten. Das heißt, es gibt da nicht mal mehr republikanischen Kandidaten. Also für Präsidentschaft gibt es fünf Kandidaten. Aber für sozusagen die Parlamentsposten gibt es jeweils nur zwei.
Also die Kandidaten gibt es schon. Es ist nicht so, dass die Republikaner aufgestellt haben.
Nicht auf dem Wahlzettel.
Ja, aber du kannst zeitlich für sie wählen.
Wie ist dann das passiert? Und dann stellt er sich raus, da gab es einen 2010, eine Nutzung der Proposition 14. Und die war eine Verfassungsänderung, wo sie festgelegt haben, dass auf dem Wahlzettel nur die beiden Kandidaten stehen, damit die weder nicht so verwirrt sind, die bei den Primaries, also bei den Vorwahlen, insgesamt von allen Kandidaten die meisten Stimmen haben. Nun muss man dazu wissen, die Vorwahlen sind ja eigentlich parteiinterne Angelegenheiten. Das heißt, die Vorwahlen finden innerhalb der Parteien statt, werden aber in Kalifornien zum Teil trotzdem mit Staatshilfe veranstaltet. Also die können da drauf zugreifen. Was die Demokraten da haben, ist ja schon seit Langem quasi eine absolute Mehrheit in Kalifornien. Die haben sie benutzt, um dafür zu sorgen, dass die beiden Top-Positionen in ihren Primaries, für Senatsposten, die haben die meisten Stimmen. Und zwar absolut von allen Kandidaten jeweils. Die haben halt irgendwie 10 oder 15 Prozent der Stimmen. Und irgendwie die anderen fangen dann bei 8 oder 9 oder so an. Und der Effekt ist nun halt, dass durch diese kleine Änderung, die am Anfang nicht so richtig klar war, also am Anfang dachten alle so, okay, der Wahlzeitl ist ein bisschen kürzer, dann stehen da nicht mehr 20 Kandidaten, da muss ich die noch mal suchen. Und zwei Kandidaten, na gut, wir haben ja eh ein, zwei Parteien-System, dann werden es schon die Kandidaten von den Demokraten und Demublikanern sein. Und haben nicht verstanden, dass das nicht der Kandidaten pro Partei mit den meisten stimmen, sondern insgesamt der Kandidaten mit den meisten stimmen.
Also diese Propositions muss man dazu erklären. Die Kalifornier haben eine, eine direktere Demokratie als der Rest der USA. Die haben regelmäßig Volksabstimmungen zu Sachen, die auch tatsächlich dann eine bindende Wirkung haben. Und da werden alle möglichen Sachen gemacht. Da kann also, ich glaube, auch so gut wie jeder Vorschläge einreichen. Das heißt, so ein üblicher Wahlzettel hat dann schon mal sowas wie 50 oder so Propositions.
Also 20 etwa.
Und das sind halt immer so Vorschläge, die jeweils mit Ja, nein zu stimmen sind. Und da steht dann jeweils ein kurzer Text, was das bedeutet. Und bei vielen von diesen Propositions, die kommen halt aus dem Parteiapparat. Und da geht es eher darum, nicht zu erklären, worum es geht, als zu erklären, worum es geht. Das heißt, die lesen sich dann auch so, dass man die dreimal liest und immer noch nicht verstanden hat, was man jetzt eigentlich da konkret stimmen soll. Vor ein paar Jahren gab es z.B. eine schwulenfeindliche Proposition, die weltweit Presse gemacht hat. Das ist nicht nur Bürokratiekram, sondern das ist durchaus handfest, was da drinsteht. Und für diese Proposition 10, oder was war das? 14?
14.
Gab es eine Mehrheit von 53 zu 47%. Also das war ultra knapp, aber es hat gereicht, um sozusagen die Demokratie abzuschaffen. Da völlig unglaublich.
Also was mich da zum Nachdenken gebracht hat, war, dass diese Wählerverwirrung, also die Welt ist zu komplex und man muss da was gegen tun. Alles, was es einfacher macht, ist eigentlich gut, die auszunutzen. Bedingt natürlich auch ein Interesse darin, dass die Wahrnehmung der Welt als ultrakomplex und völlig verwirrend verstärkt werden muss. Weil je verwirrender und komplexer die Welt ist, also je mehr du Probleme hast irgendwie noch mitzukommen, je mehr Probleme du hast irgendwie zu verstehen, was eigentlich passiert. Und je mehr du News Items siehst und liest, wo du denkst so, was? Wie jetzt? Desto mehr bist du halt in zweifel auch Villains irgendwie zu sagen, okay, dann entweder...
Lass mal die Experten machen...
.ziehe mich halt komplett aus dem Prozess zurück und irgendwie hab da überhaupt gar keine Lust mehr. Oder ich lass die Experten machen oder ich nehm die Leute mit den einfachen Antworten. Naja, also mit diesem Build a Wall.
Das Spannende ist ja, dass es schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren so ein Mem ist, dass man sagt, ja ja, das Volk ist zu blöde, um sie mitentscheiden zu lassen. Deswegen haben wir repräsentative Demokratie, auch in Deutschland ja. Die wählen nur noch irgendwie den, der ihre Probleme lösen wird. Und der Rest ist viel zu komplex. Und früher hat es gereicht, dass man nicht das einfach, dass die Politiker sich das eingeredet haben, weil die Leute eh gar nicht die Möglichkeiten hatten, sich zu informieren. Das heißt, ich halte diese Confusion Politics-Geschichte für eine Gegenreaktion auf das Internet. Weil wir jetzt plötzlich erstmalig Leute haben, die überhaupt in der Lage sind, sich selbst zumindest zu versuchen, zu informieren. Und dem muss man entgegenwirken, indem man dafür sorgt, dass erstens im Internet viel Bullshit steht und da arbeiten wir ja alle dran. Nicht zuletzt die Deutsche Welle wird ja gerade umgebaut zum Propaganda-Fernensprecher gegen Russia Today. Das ist ja irgendwie die offizielle Ansage sogar gewesen. Also wir sollten uns da nicht ausnehmen und sagen, naja, die Amis machen Halter. Das ist hier durchaus genauso.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding, wo ich halt auch mal wieder überlege. So jetzt bin ich gerade so beim Vorbereiten von einer News-Show. Scrollen wir noch mal so durchs gesamte Jahr und gucken halt, was da so irgendwie passiert ist so. Und ich denk mir halt so, naja, sind wir nicht Teil dieses Systems? Sind wir nicht Teil dieser Confusion-Politics geworden? Weil wir natürlich auf die absurdesten und schrägsten und...
Verstärker für sowas sind, ne?...
merkwürdigsten Sachen hinweisen und so. Ob nicht eigentlich vielleicht irgendwie die Aufgabe sich mittlerweile geändert hat und also eigentlich eine Einordnung und Vereinfachung wichtiger ist, als diesen...
Die Zugänglichmachung?...
diesen Newsflat zu sortieren, ja. Weil irgendwie letzten Endes ist halt irgendwie der Effekt ist halt, dass die Leute dann... Naja, ist halt dieses Oh, deal.
Na, aber dann schließt du dich ja der Entmündigung der Leute sozusagen an.
Na, tut man das.
Ja, wenn du sagst, irgendwie die sind zu blöde, das selber sortieren zu können. Ich muss sehen, davon sortieren.
Nee, ist nicht zu blöd. Ist halt einfach zu viel.
Vorsicht.
Das ist halt wirklich zu viel.
Ja, ist es ja auch.
Objektiv ist es einfach zu...
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht weniger zu viel, wenn du jetzt anders sortierst die Leute, außer du gehst davon aus, dass die sich halt nur bei dir informieren. Und das finde ich eine absolut furchtbare Vorstellung.
Nee, na gut, ich mein, ich weiß nicht genau. Du hast doch bestimmt irgendwie eine Menge Leute, die irgendwie keine anderen News-Quelle außer dich mehr lesen.
Nein, ich hoffe nicht. Ich versuche dir, mir mal entgegenzuarbeiten. Aber es ist nicht so einfach.
Naja, ich finde den Punkt halt schon wichtig, weil die Frage, welche...
Ich bin Teil des Systems, ja? Willst du mich jetzt hier beschimpfen?
Nein, ich will dich nicht beschimpfen. Natürlich nicht so zersichtlich mit dir hier. Nee, mich interessiert halt nur einfach die Frage, wie kann man dem entgegenwirken? Also ist halt mehr Information an sich, hilft ja nicht mehr. Also ist ja nicht mehr, also wenn man sagt, der Flooding, das heißt also mehr Confusion erzeugen, mehr widersprüchliche Sachen, mehr Dinge, die halt sich nicht mehr klar einordnen lassen, in den Aufmerksamkeitsfokus bringen, ist Teil des Spiels?
Na ja, warte mal, das hat ja noch einen zweiten Fuß das Problem, nämlich dass du die einzelnen Meldungen nicht mehr per se, die reichen nicht mehr als Informationseinheit. Schönes Beispiel war gerade das Ding mit den Hacks in den USA, wo dann so Meldungen rauskommen, wie unsere Geheimdienste sagen, sie hätten gute Indizien dafür, dass es die Russen waren. Punkt. Und dann zeigen sie keine einziges von den Indizien. Ja, das heißt, du kriegst ja nicht mehr Fakten rein, sondern du kriegst einfach Behauptungen rein und die kannst du halt nicht bewerten auf sich alleine. Du hast keine in sich geschlossenen Sachen mehr. Also früher, na ja, das stimmt auch nicht. Aber also in der idealen Welt würden sie dir nicht sagen, so und so ist so, weil unsere Experten das behaupten, sondern sie würden sagen, wir haben diese 15 Indizien abgewogen. Davon sprechen irgendwie zwölf dafür und drei dagegen. Daher sind wir der Meinung, das ist so. Und dann guckst du dir das an und sagst, das hat Hand und Fuß. Okay, heute hingegen kriegen wir so gut wie nie mehr irgendwelche Indizien rein, sondern die gibt es wenn überhaupt dann post facto. Also gerade mal auch bei TTIP und CETA ist es ja eine Masche, ist ja absichtlich herbeigeführt sozusagen. Alles, was du vorher gekriegt hast, waren irgendwie Behauptungen von irgendwelchen Leuten. Alles wird gut, es wird mehr Arbeitsplätze geben, pro Person 527 Euro mehr und was ist da alles für ein Scheißgab. Und du kannst keinen einzigen davon bewerten, unabhängig, weil das einfach Behauptungen sind. Und sie sagen dir nicht mehr, wie sie drauf kommen, so dass du kannst auch nicht mehr die Herleitung prüfen. Das heißt, es reicht ja nicht, dich zu verwirren, weil die Fakten ja normalerweise doch eben klar sind. Ich glaube, es ist so. Was nicht klar ist, sind Bewertungen der Fakten. Und dieser Unterschied wird immer mehr entweder erzwungen, indem man halt sagt, okay, wir geben dir die tatsächlichen Fakten gar nicht mehr, wir geben dir nur noch die bewerteten Fakten. Und im zweiten Schritt, wir sagen dir auch gar nicht mehr, wie wir zu der Bewertung gekommen sind. Das heißt, prüfen wird reduziert auf Glauben. Und so kommen wir zu der Sache, die ich ja in Twitter und sozialen Medien immer so ein bisschen kritisiert hab, dass wir überhaupt nicht mehr bewerten, was sagt der eigentlich, sondern wir bewerten nur noch, in welchem Kreis bewegt der sich gerade. Ist die Person glaubwürdig?
Mit wem hängt er rum? Wessen Argumente benutzt er?
Ja, aber das ist schon fortgeschritten. Für viele Leute geht es gar nicht mehr bis zu den Argumenten, sondern es wird immer gesagt, dieser Typ, der ist gesehen worden, wie er da hinten mit dem geredet hat und der ist böse.
Und halt gilt bei Argument Association. Aber das ist ja auch ein Vereinfachungsmechanismus. Es ist eigentlich ein Mechanismus, mit dem die Leute versuchen, sich in Zeiten, wo sie mit der Komplexität von Argumenten oder auch mit der Tatsache, dass es keine guten Antworten gibt, was ja häufig der Fall ist, nicht mehr abfinden wollen.
Na, da würde ich aber gerne selber aufdenken. Das soll bitte das Ergebnis meiner eigenen Prüfung sein und nicht irgendwie aufgeben, weil ich ein bisschen rumgugel und finde nichts.
Man darf halt nicht vergessen, dass die allermeisten Leute haben halt natürlich einfach eine limitierte intellektuelle Bandbreite. Und zwar jetzt nicht im Sinne von sie sind dumm, sondern sie haben einfach mal Anregen zu tun.
Ja klar.
Sondern sie müssen halt irgendwie ihr Geld verdienen, müssen sich um ihre Familie kümmern und haben halt irgendwie sonst noch ein paar Hobbys und Probleme, die sie heute wissen.
Das ist doch bei mir genauso. Aber es gibt halt zwei, drei Sachen, die interessieren mich und da habe ich dann eben die Zeit, mich da ein bisschen hinterher zu recherchieren. Ich habe vorhin einen Artikel gesehen, wo mir das so richtig aufgefallen ist. Google führt jetzt Fact-Checking ein, war der Artikel. Ich glaube, es war irgendwie eine Satire-Side. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich glaube, es war eine Satire-Side. Aber die Kommentare darunter waren, das ist Teil der Anti-Trump-Agenda der liberal dominierten Medien. Hier wird ja immer nur, also so ohne überhaupt zu sehen, ob die Meldung überhaupt ernst gemeint ist oder nicht, wird sofort dagegen gehauen. Also sozusagen, bei Google News ist dann irgendwie ein Plus oder ein Minus daneben, je nachdem, ob Google glaubt, dass die Meldung stimmt. Was ich persönlich ja für Bullshit halte, dass sie das hinkriegen.
Wenn sie sich eine KI dazu bauen, finde ich das gut.
Ja, haben sie. Das ist die Behauptung im Artikel. Also wir werden sehen. Ich glaube, es war eine Satire-Side. Ich bin mir aber auch nicht sicher, weil ich das jetzt nur irgendwie ein paar Sekunden im Vorbeweis gesehen habe.
Aber die Bewertungskai finde ich hier persönlich irgendwie eine gute Sache. Sollte halt nur...
Wer bewacht die Wächter, ist dann die nächste Frage. Wo kommt denn die Fakten-Basis der KI her?
Die sollte nicht allgemein sein, sondern halt mit offenen Bewertungskriterien arbeiten.
Weißt du, wenn es die Fakten gäbe, die die KI enabling ist zu prüfen, dann könnte ich da auch selber drauf kommen. Aber das ist ja gerade meine Kritik, dass es die Fakten gar nicht mehr gibt, sondern es wird nur noch gesagt, wir haben gute Beweise dafür, dass die Russen es waren und fertig und mehr gibt es halt nicht.
Genau, diese Nummer mit den Russen. Das ist ja ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie das heutzutage funktioniert. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, diese Attribution auf die Russen waren es. Bei den diversen Hexen in Usa. Dann funktioniert die eigentlich immer nach demselben Muster. Das erste ist dieser APT, Advanced Persistent Threat, also quasi ein Trojaner, der sich ein bisschen tiefer ins System gebohrt hat, wird entdeckt und die finden den halt. Dann versuchen sie, herauszukriegen, wer war es denn. Wer war es denn, wird dann attributiert auf, wir wissen es nicht so genau, aber das letzte Mal wurde die Software oder die Command-Control-Parameter zu Zeiten, wo in Moskau Business Hours sind, also zu Arbeitszeiten in Moskau verändert. Und wir haben Hinweise darauf, dass in den Direktrostrukturen irgendwie kurolische Zeichen vorkamen.
Und es weiß ja jeder, dass Hacker zu Business Hours arbeiten.
Genau. Also es ist Government-Hacker.
Ja. Und theoretische Buchstaben kann auch niemand irgendwie faken.
Aber so, dann kommt der nächste Schritt.
Also eine schwache Indizienkette. Für Leute, die jetzt technisch nicht folgen können, eine sehr schwache Indizienkette.
Eine schwache Indizienkette, die sich leicht faken lässt, aber die erstmal im ersten Report auch so als, wir wissen es nicht genau.
Aber diese Indizien sprechen dafür.
Die sprechen dafür, aber wir wissen es nicht genau. Wir wollen jetzt nicht öffentlich sagen, die waren es, aber nur so. Im zweiten Schritt wird diese Attribution dann so ein bisschen verschärft.
Also im zweiten Schritt heißt, es wird eine andere Mailware gefunden.
Beim zweiten Angriff.
Genau. Es wird eine zweite Mailware gefunden. Sie gucken sie sich an und sagen, ach guck mal, das kommt mir bekannt vor. Der Teil, der ist derselbe wie in dieser Mailware, die wir schon analysiert haben. Und schon wird aus der Indizienkette sozusagen ein schwacher Beweis. So, ja, aber das haben wir ja damals schon untersucht. Das wären wahrscheinlich wieder die russischen Seiten. Und jetzt wird dieselbe Mailware-Kette angeblich zum dritten Mal gefunden. Und jetzt ist das ein fester Beweis plötzlich. So haben wir ja schon zweimal nachgewiesen.
Wir haben es ja schon zweimal behauptet, oder wir haben es als wahrscheinlich angesehen. Und dass das zum dritten Mal passiert, muss es ja so sein.
Und jetzt kommt noch dazu, wer ist denn das eigentlich? Da hattest du gestern noch ein paar Einsichten, die wir vielleicht auch mal ausrollen können. Wer sind denn die Leute, die diese Mailware da prüfen? Die Analysen kommen ja nicht von der NSA, sondern die kommen von so Leuten wie Symantec.
Symantec, ja.
Wer arbeitet denn da?
Naja, so Leute, die halt früher bei der NSA waren zum Beispiel.
Genau, und warum sind die da weg?
Weil sie mehr Geld verdienen wollen.
Naja, nicht nur, also gestern war noch irgendwie, wir haben uns da schon ein bisschen darüber unterhalten die letzten Tage. Und eine der Sachen war, dass die einfach keinen Bock mehr drauf hatten, instrumentalisiert zu werden für irgendwelche politischen Geschichten.
Tatsächlich passiert tatsächlich durchaus, also das halt in den Diensten, aber natürlich dann auch in der Wirtschaft. Funktioniert sehr so, wenn dann halt so ein Analyst halt irgendwie seinen Bericht schreibt und sagt hier, wir haben Hinweise auf, aber in Gesamtbetrachtung von allem können wir uns nicht 100% sicher sein. Man schreibt dann halt noch so ein paar relativ in der Adjektive an seiner Konklusio ran, wo dann drin steht so, naja, also es gibt Hinweise darauf, dass es möglicherweise vielleicht die Russen gewesen sein könnten oder jemand, der so tut, als wenn er die Russen ist, steht dann da vielleicht.
Oh, und der Teil geht dann halt verloren durch die Instanzen.
Genau, und der Teil geht dann halt auf den Weg nach oben zur Behörden-Lattung halt verloren und wurde halt eben nicht mehr mitgeliefert.
Das läuft bei Diensten wie in großen Firmen, dass jeder im Grunde auf dem Weg versucht, seinen Arsch zu bedecken. Bloß nicht irgendwelche Sachen hinterlassen ohne relativierende Erklärung, die später irgendwie als Fehler gewertet oder gegenein verwendet werden könnten. Das heißt, da könnt ihr mal einen drauf lassen, dass die Dienste, wenn sie sowas analysieren, da auch nicht reinschreiben. Das waren jetzt die Russen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt die Medien kommen und sagen, wir wissen aber ganz genau, dass es die Russen waren, weil uns die Dienste das gesagt haben, dann ist das höchstwahrscheinlich auf dem Weg, ist so der Honecker-Effekt oder wie nennt man es? Snafu-Effekt haben wir das immer genannt. Auf dem Weg durch die von Vorgesetzten zu Vorgesetzten gehen die ganzen relativierenden Adjektive und Nebensätze verloren und oben kommt an, wir sind uns total sicher, das sind die Russen. Das ist inhaltlich mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit Unsinn. Denn selbst wenn es aus Russland kommt und kyrillische Zeichen drin sind, kann es immer noch irgendwie ein Hacker aus, was weiß ich, Frankreich gewesen sein oder von sonst wo, der einfach möchte, dass es aussieht, als seien es die Russen.
Oder die Chinesen.
Und im Moment ist es so, dass es waren die Russen, so die Äußerung ist, mit der alle gut leben können, aber das ist ja nicht die erste Iteration, wo die Amis wild Finger auf irgendwelche Leute zeigen, sondern es gab auch schon Fälle, wo sie gesagt haben, Chinesen, Nordkorea und sogar die Iranischen, gewiesen die nochmal, die Präsidenten Garde, revolutionäre Garde oder was will ich. Also alle möglichen Leute sind schon von den Amerikanern irgendwie bezichtigt worden und nie gab es irgendwelche Beweise. Und dadurch, dass die Presse das jetzt ein paar Mal geglaubt hat, sind wir jetzt in der vierten Iteration auch so, dass die mit einer Selbstsicherheit einfach behaupten, das sind die Russen. So, wenn ihr uns die anderen vier geglaubt habt, dann könnt ihr uns ja auch denen jetzt hier mal glauben. Also das ist so ein selbstverstärkendes System auch, dass sie überhaupt nicht mehr das glauben, darlegen zu müssen, wie sie drauf kommen. Also schon von Anfang an nicht. Aber am Anfang haben sie wenigstens noch so ein bisschen so, ja, wir haben Indizien dafür, wir glauben, es könnten die Nordkoreaner gewesen sein. Aber dass sich jetzt tatsächlich der Klepper aus dem Fenster läht und in einem öffentlichen Statement sagt, wir sind uns sicher, dass es die Russen waren, das ist also auch eine neue Qualität.
Ja, also Leute, die halt so ein bisschen auf der Darkset arbeiten oder da gearbeitet haben, sagen mir, wenn sich da so ein Geheimdienstchef oder irgendwie Obama selber aus dem Fenster lädt und irgendwelche Geräusche macht in die Richtung, wir wissen es ziemlich gut, wer es war, wir können halt nur die Beweise nicht vorlegen, dann heißt es meistens, dass sie gesehen haben, wie die Mehrwehr-Infektion oder wie es Kommand & Kontrol durch irgendeinen von den NSA-Tappingpoints durchlief. Und sie dann halt aus dem Ursprung, wo es halt herkam, den IP-Adress-Range oder durch Zurückverfolgung so irgendwie so ein Indiz dafür entwickelt haben, aus welcher geografischen Ecke das halt kam.
Könnte immer noch ein Proxy oder ein Tor oder irgendwas sein.
Kann halt immer alles Mögliche sein.
Also nichts davon ist irgendwie definitiv. Aber der Punkt ist, nehmen wir an, du hast jetzt hier ein Report geschrieben und du siehst irgendwie, und da standen 15 relativierende Klausi drin und dann siehst du irgendwie drei Tage später lehnt sich Obama aus dem Fenster und sagt, die fiesen Russen, dann gehst du wahrscheinlich bei der NSA. Wenn du noch so was wie Anstand hast, gehst du halt und fängst bei Cymantech an. Und bei der NSA rücken dann irgendwelche Leute nach, die die Erfahrung noch nicht gemacht haben. Und so ist das ein selbst verlängertes System. Die laufen in dieselbe Falle wieder rein. Und Cymantech, ich denke mal, das ist jetzt nicht so riesig wie die NSA als Firma, aber ein paar Hundert Mitarbeiter, wenn die schon auch haben. Da wird das wahrscheinlich genauso ablaufen, würde ich mal schätzen. Also ohne da jetzt irgendwelche Einblicke zu haben, dass irgendwie der Analyst schreibt halt, ja, also naja, es könnte irgendwie jemand aus dem kyrillischen Raum gewesen sein, weil wir hier diesen Directory-Namen gefunden haben. Aber das heißt ja nichts. Ja, und dann geht das durch die Instanzen und oben kommt an, in dem Pressebericht steht dann, wir haben hier Smoking Gun gegen die Russen.
Und der Punkt ist halt, sobald sie einmal damit durchgekommen sind und gesagt haben, diese Klasse von Mailware, diese Art, Mailware zu bauen, also die sind dann immer zusammengefasst unter APT, zweistellige Nummer, für Advanced Persistent Threat. Sobald sie dann diesen Fingerprint wiederfinden und sagen können, okay, diese Mailware haben wir schon mal gesehen und in dem Kontext hatten wir gedacht, das sind die Russen, also müssen es jetzt auch wieder die Russen sein. Dieses Auffinden wird natürlich umso weniger aussagefähig in mehr Zeit vergeht, weil diese Mailware...
Kann ja auch geleakt sein. Dann ist ja selbst der NSA passiert, den es gerade...
Nicht nur der NSA passiert, sondern tatsächlich die Leute, die halt irgendwie Research dauernd machen, also die halt irgendwie die Dinge auseinandernehmen, naja, die wissen natürlich, wie man da andere andere Kommandos und Kontrolls reinpatcht.
Ja, natürlich. Aber es ist ja auch ein PR-Event, ja? Weil wenn jetzt irgendwo diese Mailware auftaucht, dann steht irgendwie bei der Analyse von, ich sag mal, Sophos oder irgendein anderer Mailware-Analytiker, der schreibt dann halt, dieser Strang ist zum ersten Mal in 1900 irgendwas aufgetaucht und damals hat Cementek analysiert, es waren die Russen. Das heißt, für Cementek gibt es auch überhaupt keinen Anreiz, keinen wirtschaftlichen Anreiz, sich dann nicht aus dem Fenster zu lehnen oder das später zurückzurufen. Und das ist aus unserer Sicht die Basis für diese gesamten Attributions. Die kann man alle in einer Pfeife rauchen. Umso lustiger, dass jetzt die flinten Uschi auch gerne Cyber-Cyber haben will.
Das wird alles noch ganz wunderschön. Das ist halt wieder so ein klassischer Fall von die Hamadjis Notenentüllungen, nicht als wahres Beispiel, sondern als Einkaufswunschliste gesehen. Genau, das ist halt ihr Wunschkatalog.
Ach, das geht? Das wollen wir auch.
Eines dieser großen Probleme, die wir da immer wieder sehen, ist halt diese Abwesenheit von Wahrheit. Dass man sich halt nicht mehr darauf einigen kann, dass jetzt irgendetwas so oder so nicht war.
Und die Deutungshoheit, die Kämpfe um die Deutungshoheit, wer jetzt eigentlich sagen darf, was die Wahrheit ist und was nicht. Das folgt ja daraus sozusagen.
Genau, weil die letzten Endes dient ja dann der Fakt wieder einem Zweck, also einem politischen Zweck oder einem, was auch immer. Und sich zu vergegenwärtigen, dass die Interpretation der Wahrheit oder die Interpretation der Bits und Pieces natürlich stark abweichen kann, je nachdem, welchen Blick man darauf hat, führt jetzt natürlich dazu, dass die Meinung dazu, also was man halt denkt, genau was wir vorhin hatten, diese Hypothese von irgendwie zum Beispiel den Kriminalisten in so einem Fall, dass die sich immer mehr in den Vordergrund drängt.
Ich würde sogar noch ein bisschen ausholen und sagen, einen Trend, den man in den letzten Jahren gut beobachten kann, es gibt in der Forschung und Wissenschaft so einen Trend dazu, seine Papers auch öffentlich zu machen.
Moment, die Daten zu seinen Papers.
Moment, das ist genau, worauf ich hinaus will. Aber es gibt einen Gegentrend, dass die Leute sich nicht trauen, ihre Daten öffentlich zu machen, sondern da ist dann zwar das Paper auf der Webseite. Aber wenn man den Datensatz will, muss man eine Mail hinschreiben und betteln und begründen, wieso man jetzt die Daten haben will. Weil die Leute schon Angst haben, dass jemand sich ihre Daten anguckt und irgendwie sagt, ja, aber Moment, das hast du ja alles ganz falsch gemacht. Also es gibt eine tief sitzende Furcht davor, aus meiner Beobachtung, sich überführen zu lassen, dabei Mist gesagt zu haben. Und ich glaube, das ist nicht nur in der Forschung, sondern ist in der Politik auch dasselbe. Und im Journalismus, dass die Leute lieber ihre Karten nicht auf den Tisch legen, aus Angst, da könnte jemand kommen, der sich besser auskennt und der beweist dann, dass sich hier Mist gemacht hat.
Vielleicht nicht nur, der sich besser auskennt, sondern durchaus auch jemand, der sagt, okay, man kann diese Daten aber auch so und so interpretieren.
Also muss jetzt nicht mehr sein, mit einer anderen Hypothese, die er auch nachweisen kann.
Die er eben auch nachweisen kann an derselben Daten.
Und dann habe ich noch den anderen geholfen am Ende, so meinste, ja?
Das ist zumindest, das ist ja bei den, also bei den Klimaforschern war das ja lange Zeit, die hatten ja lange Zeit dieses Problem, dass die Temperaturkurven nicht weiter nach oben gingen, weil irgendwie wir gerade ein Solar aus dem Minimum hatten. Und daraus folgte halt eben das, naja, da war halt der Energieeintrag insgesamt geringer, deswegen gingen die Kurven halt nicht nach oben. Aber das wussten die halt nicht bis zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt und haben deswegen halt angefangen, ihre Daten zu fudgen. Nein, nicht wirklich zu fudgen, aber zumindest halt irgendwie so eine, also sagen wir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig die Rigorosität der Wissenschaft irgendwie anzulegen, die man hätte anlegen sollen, weil sie echt Angst hatten. Also jetzt auch nicht unbegründete Angst, sondern begründete Angst hatten, dass das wiederum benutzt wird, um halt zu sagen, ja, wir müssen ja nichts tun, weil Klimawandel ist ja sowieso nur irgendwie so ein Flug und irgendwie da passiert halt irgendwie ja nix.
Und das stimmt ja auch. Genau, das ist ja passiert, dass Leute dann gesagt haben, also guck mal, wir gucken uns hier die letzten fünf Jahre an und da geht es sogar ein bisschen nach unten. Ja, alles liberal hoax.
Hat ja hier geschneit, also kann es keinen Klimawandel geben.
Genau, ist also völlig berechtigt, die Furcht. Aber es führt eben dazu, dass wir hier nicht mehr auf Basis von Fakten reden oder sagen, ich würde sogar nicht nur reden, sondern verhandeln sagen. Wir verhandeln ja, was die Realität ist.
Also wenn wir dem Konstruktivismus folgen, ist dem so ja.
Wenn wir aber nicht Zugang zur Faktenbasis haben, können wir nicht zum richtigen Ergebnis kommen oder nur zufällig.
Oder mir würde es ja schon häufiger reichen, zu wissen, wie jemand zu einem Ergebnis gekommen ist.
So wie viel Confidence hast du denn in das Ergebnis? Nicht mal das kriegen wir normalerweise, sondern die Leute sagen immer, naja, slam dunk.
Genau. Und was hat sich denn irgendwie die Mechanismen dafür? Sind halt klar, so bei den Universitäten und so, die wollen halt Funding haben und die werden nach den Papers beurteilt und so weiter. Aber selbst dann mal halt mal so einen Fall nehmen, also wenn ich mir zum Beispiel halt irgendwie ein bisschen Artiforensik mache und mir zum Beispiel angehören...
Auch peggy und NSU, immer alles Slam Dunk, der Irak-Krieg, Slam Dunk. Ja, natürlich, wir haben hier Bilder von denen.
Wir haben halt eine Sehnsucht nach einfachen Wahrheiten. Also letztendlich ist es ja auch so...
Aber es führt auch dazu, dass du niemandem mehr glauben kannst, wenn alle immer nur hohe Confidence haben und genau das passiert ja auch.
Genau, was wir gerade sehen, es wird halt nichts mehr geglaubt. Und wenn ich mir so angucke, wenn ich selber so was mache, also wenn ich halt so ein bisschen Artiforensik mache, zum Beispiel mir angucke, nehme ich halt so eine Bannerie auseinander und will halt wissen, wie ist es entstanden? Wurde da zum Beispiel Code von mir geklaut oder so? Oder wurde halt irgendwie irgendwas nachher befunden? Oder wie auch immer so? Oder ist dieser Rechner infiziert? Das ist ja so ein einfaches Beispiel. So ist auf diesem Rechner halt irgendwie eine Mailware. Das ist ja ein schwieriges Problem. So, weil da sind halt irgendwie Tonnen von Software drauf und dann wirklich rausfinden, was da war, ist ohne eine Hypothese auch echt schwierig. Also du kannst nicht einfach so blind hingehen und irgendwie mal dir diese ganze Platte inhalieren und gucken, ist da jetzt irgendwie eine Mailware drauf. Sondern du musst halt schon eine Hypothese entwickeln. Okay, wie würde denn so eine Mailware vorgehen? Was wäre dann möglicherweise das Ziel von so einer Mailware? Würde die halt versuchen, aufs Mikrofon zuzugreifen oder Platten zu lesen oder Keyboard-Inputs abzugreifen. Und dann gehst du halt hin und fängst halt an dir die Software anzugucken, die halt irgendwie da, wo du wahrscheinlich denkst, dass jemand halt irgendwie mit seiner Mailware aktiv werden würde, halt irgendwie ranzugucken. Und guckst halt, ob da Sachen sind, die dir komisch vorkommen. Also ob da Prozesse sind, die da halt nicht sein sollten oder so. Oder ob da Feildaten anders sind, als sie sein sollten. Oder jedenfalls so eine so Ranhaltspunkte dafür, dass es irgendeine Normalitätsabweichung gibt. Und ohne diese Hypothese hättest du eigentlich keine Chance. Also weil die Menge der Daten halt viel zu groß ist. Also diese Hypothese ist ja unser Realitätsfilter, der es uns überhaupt erlaubt, irgendwie ab und zu mal halt irgendwie eine Quasarkette nachzuvollziehen.
Und selbst wenn wir davon ausgehen, so unter idealen Bedingungen, ja sozusagen, ich hab jetzt hier ein Windows, was ich mir mal angucken soll. Das ist ja ein bewegliches Ziel, so ein Windows. Da gibt es ständig irgendwelche Patches und Updates. Das heißt, irgendwie zu sagen, eine Hintertür kann auch heißen einfach, dieser Patch ist nicht eingespielt worden und jetzt kann ich halt die Sicherheitslücke ausnutzen, die der hätte patchen sollen. Das heißt ja nicht, da ist Software da, die nicht da sein sollte. Das kann auch heißen, da ist Software nicht da, die da sein sollte. Oder da ist zwar alle Software da, die da sein sollte, aber in der falschen Version. Das ist alles nur sehr schwer zu klären. Und da jetzt irgendwelche Absicht zu unterstellen, ist grundsätzlich im Grunde auch immer nur eine Hypothese. Das lässt sich nicht beweisen. Und im Allgemeinen, wenn man sich wirklich mal so ein Windows anguckt und nach Malware sucht, das funktioniert in der Praxis so, dass der Hauptfokus darauf liegt, später nachweisen zu können, dass ich als Untersucher nicht versehentlich die Datenbasis geändert habe. Das heißt, da gibt es dann irgendwie, man zieht eine Bitkopie von der Festplatte.
Also, die man dann nicht mehr modifiziert.
Das allein dauert schon einen Tag, als Größenordnung. Also, kommt natürlich darauf an, was die für Platten haben, aber so, das dauert Arschlange. Und dann gibt es Spezial-Hardware, die man zwischen den Rechner und die Platte schaltet, die Schreibzugriffe wegmacht. Das heißt, ich kann die Platte analysieren, ohne dass zum Beispiel das Windows sagt, oh, die Platte ist nicht sauber runtergefahren worden, da geräum ich jetzt mal auf oder so. Oder da sind noch irgendwelche Updates eingetragen, die nach dem Boot eingespielt werden sollen. Und dann würden die meine Daten verändern. Also um das auszuschließen, wird Aufwand getrieben. Aber der Rest ist bei weitem nicht so rigoros, sondern da werden dann irgendwelche kommerziellen Tools gestartet auf die Platte. Und die gucken dann in die Browser-Historie. Also ich übertreibe das jetzt ein bisschen, aber im Wesentlichen ist es so. Man guckt irgendwie, ach, guck mal hier. Hier ist irgendwie die Autostart-Liste. Und hier könnte sich eine Browser-Extension eingetragen haben. Und es gibt so drei, vier Punkte, die man halt guckt. Aber das ist es auch, ja. Das heißt, auf Basis von so was, irgendwelche Aussagen zu machen, gehen immer zuerst von der Hypothese aus, dass der Typ, von dem ich da grad die Platte untersuche, mich nicht kommen sah und absichtlich hier falsche Spuren gelegt hat. Denn wenn sobald das eine Möglichkeit ist, ist die gesamte Analyse für einen Arsch. Das muss man einfach mal so durchsagen. Also wenn du jetzt nach Kopien von deiner Software suchst, dann ist es zwar auch ein bewegliches Ziel, aber du weißt zumindest, wonach du es suchst. Du hast eine Hypothese, die du vergleichen kannst.
Und ich meine, wenn ich Glück habe, dann finde ich halt eine bitidentische Kopie. Also wir hatten einmal so einen Fall, da war es halt irgendwie tatsächlich ein Pfeil. Du warst halt wirklich bitidentisch, wo wir nachweisen konnten, okay, dieses Pfeil wurde halt erzeugt von... Ganz schlau. Und die war dann halt da in der Kopie drin.
Also Leute, wenn ihr von Frank klaut, stellt euch schlauer an, das ist hier langweilig.
Um nochmal auf diese Russland-Attribution zurückzukommen, der Großteil der Attribution findet ja auf der Basis von QBono statt. Also wem nutzt es? Wir haben hier, sehen hier, da ist irgendwas, wir haben hier so eine Mailware gefunden, wir wissen auch, dass es eine Mailware ist, schon mal ein großer Schritt. Wir sehen, die kommuniziert, die Server steht in Russland. Und wer hätte denn jetzt ein Interesse daran, die Wahlen in Amiland halt irgendwie zu konfusionieren, kann man ja nur so sagen.
So, und jetzt gehen wir mal einen Schritt zurück und gucken uns an, wie Verschwörungstheorien funktionieren. Und wir stellen fest, genau so.
Exakt genauso.
Ja. Ja, wer hätte denn noch ein Interesse daran, dass eine Mailware bei der Bundeswehr gefangen wird? Das ist ja auch die Bundeswehr, denn die kriegt mehr Budget, wenn sie nachweisen kann, dass es hier ein Cyberproblem gibt und dass sie im Moment nicht materiell oder personell ausgestattet sind, um dem entgegenzutreten. Aber soweit gehen die Kui, Bruno und Elisandre nicht, sondern das untersucht ja dann gewöhnlich auch jemand, der bei der Bundeswehr für Cyber zuständig ist oder jetzt gerade frisch ausgebaut, der Bereich. Und die sagen dann, naja, also das wird ein Russie gewesen sein.
Also interessant daran finde ich ja primär, dass es ja offensichtlich immer so eine Art Dienstanweisung gibt, wer es denn war.
Und zwar bevor die Analyse losgeht.
Und früher waren es halt immer die Chinesen. Also ich erinnere mich so von so anderthalb Jahren. Also bis vor etwa anderthalb Jahren waren es eigentlich immer die Chinesen. Also es gab halt eigentlich nichts anderes. Es war halt so, wenn immer irgendwo Cyber war, waren es halt die Chinesen. Und dann ist Obama nach China gefahren und hat mit der chinesischen Führung geredet. Und sie haben halt irgendwas über Cyber geredet. So irgendeiner, es gab da irgendwas, so eine Art irgendwie Nichtangriffsding wurde gemunkelt oder was auch immer.
Sie sind sich einig, dass die Russen der eigentliche Feind sind.
Und plötzlich schwenkte das um. Im Internet gibt es ja diese schönen Attribution Dice, also die Attributionswürfel. Und die gibt es in der Variante zufällig und in der Variante loaded. Also mit dem Gewicht drin, der halt was halt dafür sorgt, dass immer eine Seite nach oben oder nach hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit nach oben kommt. Früher stand da aber hier oben und jetzt steht da natürlich Russland oben. Also wollen wir jetzt nur mal kurz überlegen, also nehmen wir mal an.
Warum eigentlich gibt es da irgendwie handfeste Gründe? Sind die irgendwann auf frischer Tat ertappt worden? Ich meine, die ganzen wirklich krassen Dinger, so Stucks nennen so, das ist ja inzwischen auf den Westen attribuiert worden. Eigentlich wäre doch der smarte Move jetzt immer zu sagen, na dann wären es wohl die gewesen sein.
Ja, ist ja auch nicht auszuschließen. Also gut, ich meine, ich würde jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass die NSA irgendwie den E-Mail Server von den Democrats hacken musste.
Nein, aber dass deren Mailware da geleakt sein könnte oder so. Der Punkt ist ja, dass ich ja auch sowieso mich überhaupt nicht versuche, die Leute zu zu finden, sondern alles, was diese Analysen machen, ist, das Tool zurück zu verfolgen.
Genau.
Und das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, die Bundeswehr auf schattigem Wege sich die Mailware oder die Chinesen oder die Chinesen sich die Mailware Baukasten der Russen gekauft haben, weil die irgendwie oder auf ihren Server gefunden im Darkweb werden die ja verkauft oder auf ihren Server gefunden oder auf ihren eigenen Server. Das wäre natürlich peinlich, aber da fehlt ja dann irgendwie der CNC-Kanal.
Ja, den kannst du rumpatchen.
Kannst du auch einen Spezialisten vom CCC ranholen, der dir da irgendwie das Protokoll reverse. Das haben wir schon gemacht, wenn du dich erinnerst.
Für die Staatskanzlerin, ja.
O-Zopf-Düss. Ja, das geht alles technisch, das heißt diese ganzen Attribuierungen, die kann man alle im Grunde in der Pfeife rauchen. Das ist also im Grunde wilde Spekulation und nicht glaubwürdiger, als wenn ich in meinem Blog irgendwas behaupte. Na ja, also so leid mir das tut, ja.
Also ein grundsätzliches Problem dabei ist die Art zu denken über solche Konflikte, weil die Russen, also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die da schon mitspielen und ich gehe auch davon aus, dass ein Teil der Sachen, wo sie den Russen zuschreiben, wahrscheinlich wirklich von den Russen ist.
Ja klar, warum auch nicht.
Warum auch nicht, genau. Und die sind ja da jetzt auch nicht besonders, naja, wie soll ich sagen, Subtil. Subtil, ja. Also in ihrem Abstreiten haben die ja dann doch immer noch irgendwie lustige Relativierungen, oder speziell...
Und grinsen dann auch immer so schön.
Und grinsen immer so schön, genau.
Aber du hast gestern noch einen Punkt gemacht, den ich sehr wichtig finde, nämlich dass innerhalb der Behörden, also jetzt sagen wir mal Bundeswehr oder Demokraten oder NSA, auch ein ungeheurer Druck aufgebaut wird, einen Feind zu haben...
Genau, weil ein Feind kann abschrecken. Das ist das, was ich mit dem Denkmund heute.
Das brauchen sie für ihr Denkmodell, dass es jemanden gibt, der das war und dass sie den auch irgendwie, dass sie mit dem Finger zeigen können, dass es einen in den Laden gibt, gegen den man jahrelang Krieg führen kann.
Zurückschlagen. Also jetzt haben wir gerade diese, wo die Amis halt herum munkeln. Die CIA plant jetzt gerade den Cyber-Konterangriff.
Die beiden hat sich hier gerade aus dem Fenster gelehnt, während wir die Show machen.
Und die Denke, die dahintersteht, ist natürlich eine sehr einfache, die sagt nämlich...
Da sind halt kalte Krieger, ne?
Also meine Völker pissbarst, wenn du weißt, wo der Feind ist, hat der Tag Struktur, ja?
So sieht's aus, ja.
Und genau diese Denke, da können die halt auch nicht von runter. Und letztendlich ist es ja auch genau nachvollziehbar, weil also wenn du...
Da sind die 40, 60 Jahre gut mitgefahren, ja? Das funktioniert einfach noch völlig menschlich.
Weil es ist ja genau dasselbe, wie so wer jetzt halt irgendwie AfD mit Märkern muss weghaben. Die haben sich jetzt einen Feind gesucht. Und jetzt hat der Tag Struktur.
An dem können sie sich jetzt abreiben.
Ja, es gibt halt... Also wenn du ein Feindbild hast, dann kannst du im Zweifel dir die Welt so zurechtbiegen, dass du einem Schlechten in dieser Welt ist dieser Feind schuld. Ja, also wie auch immer es ist. Und dieses Danke Merkel, dieses...
Thanks Obama.
Genau, die Thanks Obama. Das ist ja genau das, was dahinter steht. Dieses du willst dich eigentlich nicht mehr damit befassen, was wirklich passiert ist, sondern du willst eigentlich nur noch... Also nimmst du deinen Confirmation-Bias und schrumpfst ihn auf irgendwie deinen erkannten Feind zusammen. Und so funktionieren die Sicherheitsbehörden schon immer. Die sowas, was wir damals irgendwie den momentan anvisierte Feindbild, also MAF, nannten, ob es jetzt irgendwie Nazis oder wie Kindermissbraucher oder was auch immer.
Organisierte Kriminalität.
Organisierte Kriminalität, Rockerkriminalität oder was auch immer. Also jedenfalls, das gerade momentan anvisierte Feindbild ist ja dann immer an allem schuld. So und ich meine, was wir jetzt ja haben, ist ja dieser krasse Feindbild-Merger, dieser Zusammenschluss von Kindermissbraucher zu Nazis. Also wir haben ja sozusagen gerade Multifeind.
Wenn du dir mal diesen Ermittler Gaia anguckst, sein Fehler sowohl im peggy- als auch im NSU-Ding war genau das, dass er nur auf das momentan anvisierte Feindbild ermittelt hat. Der hat halt gesagt, okay peggy, das wird hier irgendwie ein Ausländer gewesen sein, ja. Dieser geistig behinderte Typ war irgendwie türkischer Abstammung wohl. Und bei NSU hat er auch gesagt, naja, das sind irgendwie Türken, die sich gegenseitig verkloppen, weil organisierte Kriminalität aus irgendwie osteuropäischen Ländern war damals das momentan anvisierte Feindbild. Und da hat er halt hintermittelt. Ja, und das ist wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht auf seinem Mist gewachsen, sondern es haben ihm halt seine Chefs da reingereicht. Das war halt irgendwie politische Order. Mach mal hier, ist doch völlig klar, wer das war, finde mal Beweise.
Ich bin nicht mal sicher, dass es politische Order war.
Aber sowas funktioniert ja halt implizit, ohne dass du das ansagen musst.
Dass der Confirmation-Bias halt irgendwie dafür sorgt, dass du die Fakten oder die Bits und Pieces, muss ja nicht mal Fakten sein, oder Aussagen von Leuten, die nicht zu deiner Hypothese passen, ignorierst du, weil du sie als Zeitverschwendung betrachtest. Also weil du sagst, okay, das passt jetzt nicht dazu, das kann das nicht, also das stellt ja meine Hypothese in Frage.
Ja, nee, also Zeitverschwendung ist, glaube ich, ein zu krasses Wort. Das ist eher so, dass man dann anfängt. Ich meine, wir reden ja selbst in Strafverfahren jetzt von Justizeffizienz. Die Argumentation für diese Deals, das ist ja auch, was ja völlig hanebüchen ist, die Justiz soll gerade nicht effizient sein, sondern soll die Wahrheit finden. Aber diese Idee, dass man begrenzte Mittel hat und muss sie möglichst sinnvoll anwenden, um zum guten Ergebnis zu kommen, das heißt ja nicht, dass ich das jetzt nicht betrachte, weil es meine Hypothese kippen könnte, sondern ich sage halt, okay, ich bin mir mit meiner Hypothese hinreichend sicher, dass ich jetzt mich auf die Sachen konzentriere, wo ich den meisten Impact für erwarte. Dass du sagst, ich glaube, nichts von dem ist irgendwie böse gemeint oder ich ignoriere das jetzt, weil es meine Hypothese kippen könnte, sondern das sind Effizienzerwägerungen, weil wir einfach überall diesen McKinsey-Bertelsmann-Stiftung irgendwie Ökonomisierungsscheiß drin haben inzwischen. Ja, sogar in Schulen ist inzwischen durchökonomisiert.
Also bei der Justiz würde ich dir dazustimmen, an der Politik glaube ich, ist es anders. Weil da ist es ja häufiger so, dass wird ja absichtlich eingesetzt. Wenn wir uns jetzt zu Trump angucken, was der tut ist, der gibt sich ja mit der Wahrheit überhaupt nicht mehr ab. Oder den Fakten oder was auch immer, sondern der redet einfach Dinge nur, damit sie irgendwie hängen bleiben irgendwie und die halt so einfach sind in einfacher Sprache, dass irgendwie jeder sie versteht und jeder sich da irgendwie hinterstellen kann, der so ungefähr grob seiner Meinung ist. Und dadurch, dass die Motivation der Leute, die ihn wählen ja mittlerweile ist, wreck the system, also das System kaputt machen, irgendwie es dem Establishment zu zeigen, was ja auch bei den AfD wieder durchaus eine große Motivation ist, ist es denen auch total egal. Also das ist jetzt so ein, die lügen uns sowieso alle andern, nämlich wesentlich den Lügner der Entertaining ist und verspricht, das System kaputt zu machen.
Ja, also ich hab das ja neulich in meinem Blog formuliert, als dass du versuchst einen Schraubenschlüssel ins Uhrwerk zu werfen, in die Zahnräder. Und je mehr schlechte Scheiße über Trump rauskommt, desto mehr bist du überzeugt davon, den richtigen Schraubschlüssel gefunden zu haben. Aber ich bin immer mehr der Meinung, dass wir daran auch Hillary die Schuld geben müssen. Nicht nur wegen diesem Pied Piper, sondern für uns ist neulich aufgefallen, dass es da eine zeitliche Koinzidenz zwischen dem ein Wikileaks-Mail-Dump gab. Und 30 Minuten später tauchte dieses Video auf von Trump aus diesem Lockerroom-Dings, wo er irgendwie damit rumgeprotzt hat, dass er Frauen einfach zwischen die Beine greift und sie würden dann schon nichts sagen. Das heißt, es wirkte so, als wenn sozusagen die Demokraten das schon in der Tasche hatten. Das heißt, die haben da ihren Kompromat-Fulder. Und vielleicht haben sie deswegen Trump und nicht die anderen beiden genommen, die dann noch zur Wahl standen, die auch hinreichend abgefahren gewesen sind können, weil sie da einfach mehr Kompromat gehabt haben. Also es wirft auf mich gerade so ein bisschen, dass Hillary und ihre Leute haben halt gegen alle schön Research gemacht. So macht man das heutzutage im Wahlkampf.
Opposition Research.
Die Deutschen gucken sich das übrigens auch gerade ab von den Amis. Das ist seit ein paar Jahren ein Trend, dass man nicht nur sich das abguckt, sondern auch tatsächlich die Personen einstellt, die im Obama-Wahlkampf so erfolgreich waren. Also Opposition Research ist ein Ding, was ganz groß im Kommen ist. Und ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass das alles ein völlig abgekartetes Spiel ist. Dass die einfach gesagt haben, okay, also ist uns ganz recht, wenn es Trump wird, weil gegen den haben wir ja so viel Scheiße erzählt über die Jahre, den können wir nach belieben wegbomben. Und wer weiß, wie viel die da noch im Keller haben. Also jetzt was jetzt...
Und dann waren sie davon überrascht, dass es seine Hardcore-Supporter, weil er mit diesem Wreck the System angetreten ist, einfach nicht interessiert.
Nicht nur nicht interessiert, sondern den Gegenteiligen gefechtert, dass sie plötzlich sagen, ach die Hillary ärgert sich so sehr, hier Kompromat rauszuholen. Sie haben den richtigen. Aber es ist noch nicht die Mehrheit. Also ich befürchte trotzdem, dass Trump das werden kann, weil einfach Hillary in unserem Part von dem Hahn ist. Und einfach fürchte ich, dass genügend viele Leute schon noch schnell irgendwie umschwenken in letzter Minute und sagen, ne, also Hillary kann es auch nicht werden. Wir werden sehen.
Dann wird es eigentlich vorständig non-linear.
Ja, aber ich meine, die Vorstellung, dass dieser gesamte Wahlkampf im Grunde gemanagt ist von dem Wahlkampfteam von Hillary, finde ich absolut faszinierend, ob da jetzt was dran ist oder nicht. Die Vorstellung, das ist wie so ein Sci-Fi Buch für mich, weißt du, dass man irgendwie die Vorstellung, dass jemand auf dem Niveau sich nicht nur seine Gegner dahin instrumentalisiert, die er da gern haben will, weil er sie vielleicht bekämpft behält, sondern dann auch noch in dieser Art von Timing hat, um irgendwie, okay, dann hauen wir jetzt mal das erste Kompromat raus. Und es ist ja auch wirklich so ein Trickle-Ding, wie wir uns damals bei WikiLeaks noch geärgert haben, wenn du dich erinnerst, als die angefangen haben, ihre Sachen da rauszutrickeln immer und nicht irgendwie einmal einen großen Klopper zu bringen, sondern die haben halt analysiert, der Impact ist höher, wenn wir das ein bisschen hinaus zögern und haben dann halt einmal pro Woche irgendwie was gehabt. Und so macht Hillary das auch gerade mit Trump. Also für mich wird das... Natürlich, aber so sehr die sich gegenseitig bekämpfen, die in den Mitteln sind, sind sie sich nicht so unähnlich. Das finde ich sehr ironisch an der Stelle.
Ja, andererseits, also meint aus den geleakten Mails von Team Hillary, entsteht nicht der Eindruck, als wären sie da zu einer Lage.
Als wären das die Super-Villains, das stimmt auch. Aber die Vorstellungen sind nicht trotzdem sexy.
Also, dass sie halt irgendwie in der Lage sind, halt irgendwie Storys zu timen, die sie noch im Keller haben und dass sie ihr Kompromat also nahe professionell managen, glaube ich sofort. Das halte ich für unbesehen so. Aber dass sie halt in der Lage sind, also über so einen Trump wäre uns ja der liebste Gegner, weil gegen den haben wir mehr, zu hinauszugehen und das zu sagen, als eine vollständig gemanagte Demokratie ist, glaube ich noch nicht. Also dafür sind die einfach so unprofessionell.
Das ist aber auch eine Strategie, die ich zum Beispiel immer gerne fahre, wenn mir damals im CCC irgendjemand eine Aufgabe übermitteln wollte, auf die ich überhaupt keinen Bock hab. Dann bist du strukturell inkompetent.
Du bist quasi Falschserver oder so.
Dann bist du strukturell inkompetent und verkackst das an wichtiger Stelle, damit die Leute das nächste Mal jemand anders nehmen. Das ist ja nun keine neue Idee.
Aber Hillary will ja schon gewinnen.
Ja, natürlich. Aber dass sie gelegentlich mal einen Fehler macht, um menschlich auszusehen, das ist, glaube ich... Also der Punkt ist ja auch nicht, ob ich glaube, dass diese konkreten Personen das tun könnten, sondern die Vorstellung insgesamt ist eine neue Gedankenkonstruktion für mich. Das ist eine Wahl auf dem Niveau... Weißt du, in meiner Gedankenwelt sind so gemanagte Demokratien, so was wie die DDR, wo du halt nur eine wirkliche... Du konntest halt nur die SID und ein paar Blockflöten wählen und die Auswirkungen waren null. Aber dass jemand das gesamte Spektakel inszeniert, das finde ich plötzlich nicht mehr ausgeschlossen. Dieser Gedanke ist neu für mich. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Demokraten schlau genossen sind, das jetzt konkret durchzuziehen.
Ich glaube, die sind noch nicht da.
Aber es wäre möglich und das finde ich faszinierend.
Na ja, das ist halt Sokov. Also Sokov hat ja genau das in Russland gemacht. Er hat ja Oppositionsparteien gegründet und hat...
Dann haben wir dann gegen jemanden gefragt.
Und hat das dann ja... Der nennt das ja auch durchaus gemanagte Demokratie.
Wobei das ja eine ironische Wiederverwendung eines Begriffs ist, den die Amis erfunden haben für Russland, was ich absolut großartig finde. Die Russen haben einfach genug Humor, dann den Begriff zu übernehmen.
Na ja, und am Ende ist es ja dann auch die Wahrheit. Zumindest für Russland.
Na hier noch auch. Ich war halt, hallo? Naja, nicht in dem Stil.
Nee, also da sind wir noch nicht.
Also aber, dass hier Demokratie gemanagt wird. Ich meine, also weißt du, wenn ich mir angucke, wie viel Einfluss neulich in der Anstalt gab, so einen wunderbaren, so ein Tafel-Ding wieder, wo sie erzählt haben, wie viel Einfluss der einzelne Bürger tatsächlich darauf hat, wer in welcher EU-Institution was macht. Und das war im Grunde zu vernachlässigen. Also in der Beziehung sind wir schon auch eine Männisch-Indianin.
Ach stimmt, das war das, wo er den Trilog erklärt hat.
Ja, ja, also wo als ein absoluter Guckst du dich an und denkst so, ja wieso, also das ist ja nicht wahr. Und das stimmt natürlich, ja ich mecke da ja auch seit Jahren drüber. Die einzigen, wo wir so ein bisschen Einfluss haben, sind das Parlament, aber die können keine Gesetze vorschlagen.
Technisch können sie schon.
Nee, sie können, also freundlich irgendwie, aber das hat keinerlei.
Also EU-Parlament meinst du? Ja, das stimmt ja, das ist korrekt.
Und das ist ja wohl eine absolute Farce. Das gesamte System ist eine Farce. Aber gut.
Die Frage ist halt, was denn daraus folgt. Also weil die, ich meine, was wir gerade sehen, ist ja, dass die, wir haben die Schnur zu voll davon und wir wollen jetzt irgendwas anderes. Widerschaft wird ja gerade von halt so den xenophoben Nationalisten hijackt. Also sind ja halt irgendwie so AfD, Front National und so. Also die halt nach einfachen Antworten suchen, die einfache Feindbilder haben wollen, deren Kernversprechen halt die Reduktion der Komplexität der Welt auf irgendwie einfache Schuldzuweisungen ist. Und die etablierten Parteien haben sich da halt einfach in so einer Ecke manövriert. Weil sie, also das erinnert diese Argumentation von Tarni DDR übrigens, die auch da war es ja so, wenn man gesagt hat, okay, ja, ich meine eigentlich Sozialismus ist eigentlich eine ganz coole Idee, so irgendwie Gerechtigkeit und so.
Aber diese Leute da.
Wo zwar das Auskommen für alle und so, aber dieses hier und da und da bin ich ja nicht mit einverstanden. Da haben sie gesagt, hey, komm noch in die SED. Weil die eigentliche Demokratie findet innerhalb der Partei statt. Na, das ist die innerparteiliche Demokratie. Siehst du von außen zwar nicht, weil da lassen wir nur die Genossen reingucken, aber komm noch zu uns und dann kannst du hier was verändern. Das war das, was die Leuten gesagt haben, die jetzt nicht sozusagen eine fundamental Opposition zum System waren, weil sie aus welchen Gründen noch immer.
Und die wurden dann aufgeraucht in irgendwelchen.
Und das hat tatsächlich lange Jahre funktioniert. Dadurch haben die halt durchaus Leute, die halt irgendwie klug waren und irgendwie was verändern wollten und die Idee eigentlich ganz cool fand im Prinzip, da reinbekommen. Und ich glaube, dass die Parteien in der Bundesrepublik sind an demselben Punkt, das nämlich nicht mehr funktioniert. Also die Piraten waren so der erste Anzeichen dafür, dass die dieses hey, komm noch zu den Grünen oder komm noch irgendwie zur SPD oder was auch immer. Und hier kannst du mit der Macht des Parteiapparates so die Dinge verändern. Und ich meine, auch dieser Skandal mit dem Sexismus in der CDU war ja eigentlich genau dasselbe Ding. Die scheinen ja offenbar genau dasselbe Ding zu machen. Und sie sagen so, hey, komm noch zu uns.
Haben sie versucht, den jungen Frauen zu sagen.
Kannst du was verändern?
Genau, verändert das System von ihnen.
Und backfired natürlich den Mutalen.
Und dann ist es natürlich doof, wenn du die dann irgendwie begrabscht.
Und ich glaube, dass diese Struktur des Vernachlässigens von Demokratie, bei der man das Gefühl von Selbstwirksamkeit hat. Also wo du sagst, okay, hier habe ich jetzt Arbeit reingesteckt, hier habe ich versucht, irgendwas zu verändern. Und dann ist auch was passiert. Also ich kann sehen, dass ich irgendwie was verändert habe. Und das Abzuschaffen führt halt dazu, dass die Leute dann am Ende sagen so, ich kann zwar das System nicht verändern, aber ich kann es wenigstens kaputt machen. Und ich kann wenigstens denen das da irgendwie zeigen. So und da halt irgendeine, also das sind wiederum diese Selbstwirksamkeit. Die sind, hey, die AfD hat 12 Prozent gewonnen und eine Stimme davon war meine. Und jetzt gehen die mal hin und machen das kaputt.
Weißt du, ich frage mich, ob der Auslöser nicht ist, dass diese ganzen Korruptionsermittlungen gegen FIFA laufen. Weil früher bist du nämlich zum Fußball gegangen, wenn du mit der Politik unzufrieden warst. Da gibt es dieses wunderschöne Chomsky-Interview, wo er beschreibt, wie er sich mit irgendwelchen Leuten unterhält. Und die können keinen einzigen Minister ernennen. Aber sie können dir sozusagen die Mannschaften der Champions League iterieren. Wer da mitspielt, wer der Trainer ist, wer beim Baseball wann wie weit geschossen hat. Und er meinte, das sind alles Informationen, die auf ihr Leben null Auswirkungen haben. Und die sind an der Stelle in ihrem Gehirn, wo die eigentlich über Politik hätten nachdenken sollen. So, das war seine These. Das ist jetzt auch schon viele Jahre her. Aber die These halte ich nach wie vor für valide.
Und du denkst, dass die FIFA...
Ich glaube dadurch, dass die FIFA jetzt so als korrupter Scheißladen irgendwie enttarnt wurde, was ja eigentlich auch schon immer klar war. Aber wenn du es nicht sehen willst, guckst du halt nicht hin. Aber derzeit ist es halt vorbei. Seit dieser eine Typ, dieser Künstler, mit dem Sack voller Spielgeld, irgendwie über Blatter das Geld hat regnen lassen, ist es vorbei mit der Illusion. Ja, da war dann Ende. Und ich frage mich, ob das damit zusammenhängt, dass einfach Sport inzwischen auch als korrupt wahrgenommen wird und dass man sagt, da kann ich auch in der Politik bleiben.
Du meinst, das letzte Renti ist weggefallen dadurch, weil die Doping-Skandale waren ja.
Und das haben sie ja auch versucht, gegen die Russen zu drehen. Vielleicht gibt es da auch einen Zusammenhang. Aber wollen wir nicht zu weit.
Zumindest als Aspekt ist es eine Hypothese. Was ich ja wirklich faszinierend finde, ist, dass der Frost so groß ist und kombiniert mit dem Willen, nicht genau hinzugucken, dass die AfDler es ja schaffen, die Leute dazu zu bringen, gegen ihre Interessen zu stürmen. Also wenn man sich das AfD...
Das ist ja mit Trump genauso. Weißt du, ich frag mich ja, ist nicht Trump und AfD dasselbe Phänomen?
Ja, ist es.
Aber dann muss ich mich ja fragen, entweder ist Trump dann auch irgendwie rechtsnational. Er hat so ein paar Äußerungen gemacht, aber er hat jetzt nicht. Also abgesehen von...
Er ist schon fremdenfeindlich.
Natürlich. Ja, also aber er hat jetzt diese Mauer-Geschichte halt und irgendwie die Frage der Ausweisung der Mexikaner, aber das wirkt jetzt irgendwie auf auf niemanden wirklich so, als wenn er dann wirklich eine Mauer bauen will, sondern das war er so. Meinst du wirklich, der fängt an eine Mauer zu bauen?
Ey, seine Fans sagen noch... Hast du dieses Interview gesehen mit diesem Typ? Ja, ja. Der meinte, wenn Trump gewählt wird und der Bautiermauer nicht, dann kommen wir nach Washington mit unseren Waffen.
Ja, das fand ich auch sehr spannend. Ich glaube, da hat aber Trump nicht mitgerechnet. Ich glaube, Trump hat das nur so erzählt, weil er dachte, da kriegt er irgendwie Zuspruch mit. Aber dann ist auf der anderen Seite die Frage, ob man nicht Sachen, die wir über Trump analysiert haben, auch bei der AfD mal prüfen muss. Ob die nicht auch einfach nur das Ziel haben oder irgendwie den Stimmenanteil ansprechen, der das System kaputt machen will. Weil bei der AfD haben wir ja auch den einen oder anderen Skandal gehabt. Und das hat die Leute nicht interessiert.
Jetzt gerade Sachsen-Anhalt, ne?
Vielleicht ist es einfach dasselbe. Vielleicht ist es dasselbe Phänomen, dass die Leute sagen, ist mir doch scheißegal, ich wähle die nicht, damit es besser wird, sondern um damit es in die Luft fliegt.
Um es mal hart zu sagen. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass der einzige Grund, warum die Piraten das so weit geschafft haben, trotzdem sie als Partei irgendwie völlig indiskutabel waren, was irgendwie internen Prozesse und so weiter angeht, war unter anderem genau dieses, dass die Leute gesagt haben, so ja, also bis es dann halt zu bunt wurde, klar.
Ich will das Haus brennen sehen.
Genau. Ich will halt irgendwie, dass sich irgendwas verändert. Also, wenig die jetzt halt mal und dass da halt eine Menge Leute waren, die durchaus coole Ideen hatten und irgendwie die guten Absichten hatten, die sich dann halt irgendwie zerfleischt haben, hat die Leute halt erstmal eine Weile nicht interessiert. Irgendwann dann natürlich schon.
Dass man sowas immer erst danach merkt, wenn du das von vornherein als Weltbild gehabt hättest, hättest du mit den Piraten ja richtig was machen können.
Wie meinst du?
Na wenn du da als Pirat, ich glaube viele Piraten sind zerschellt an den ganzen Umständen, weil sie nicht gemerkt haben, dass sie von Leuten gewählt werden, die das System kaputt machen wollen zumindest teilweise. Und die haben dann Ansprüche gehabt, die mit der Realität nichts zu tun hatten. Und da haben dann, weißt du, das Problem ist ja, dass Politiker, sobald es Leute gibt, die sie wählen, glauben, die werden wegen ihrer, denen gegen dem, was sie für wichtig halten, gewählt.
Deswegen die Parteiprogramme, ja.
Wenn du dich von dem Gedanken verabschiedest, kannst du, glaube ich, viel freier versucht, in der Politik Sachen zu ändern.
Dann kann Martin Sonderborn vielleicht doch noch Bundeskanzler werden.
Das fände ich richtig geil. Aber ich kenne mir den auch als Bundespräsident richtig gut vorstellen. Einfach rumreisen, unser Land vertreten. Oh, wäre das schön. Ab und zu mal eine Rede halten. Das wären tatsächlich Reden, die ich mal sehen wollen würde.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall echt interessant. Das interessante daran ist ja, wenn man halt dieses Protestpotenzial, was die AfD ja gerade tut, in so einer Art und Weise hijackt, indem sie halt irgendwie nur so auf die Basisinstinkte, also irgendwie fremde, böse Systeme muss kaputt anspricht. Was also die drei, also die beiden großen Säulen sind ja irgendwie wir wollen hier weniger Ausländer und irgendwie das System ist scheiße. Und dann darunter aber ist ja dieser ganze neoliberale Soßenkram, also zwar so richtig hardcore mit irgendwie Abschaffung von irgendwie Arbeitslosenversicherungen und so diese, also alles was...
Euro ist scheiße.
Na gut, Euro kann man drüber diskutieren, ob das ein Scheiß oder nicht.
Ja, aber das war die erste These der Partei, wenn man sich mal erinnert. Das war irgendwie heute überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Partier, oder?
Nein, das war halt ihr Claim to Fame für System kaputt machen. Also das war halt die Kerntese für, wir sind diejenigen, die gegen den Status Quo sind. Aber wenn du dir anguckst, was jetzt also in dem Parteiprogramm steht, das ist ja, denkst du dir, was ist denn das?
Ich glaube, dass der Großteil der Partei überhaupt keine Ahnung hat, was in dem Parteiprogramm steht.
Oder es ist ihnen egal.
Das heißt, du kannst auch nicht, nicht der Wähler der Partei, der Leute in der Partei.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Und ich glaube, dass du auch überhaupt das Parteiprogramm irgendwie zu nehmen, um die Partei zu bewerten, ist völlig falsch. Auch bei den anderen Parteien. Ich mach das natürlich gerne, weil man da schönen, komödiantischen Effekt daraus ziehen kann.
Was willst du denn sonst nehmen? Also, ich meine, welche, welche?
Das ist ja alles, die kommitten sich ja zunächst. Da steht ja nichts drin irgendwie. Und wenn wir das nicht machen, treten wir freiwillig zurück. Das wäre ja mal was. Aber so ist es ja nicht. Und damit kann man das irgendwie nehmen, um sie sozusagen als als als Doppel, ihre Doppelmoral zu überführen. Aber du kannst halt nicht sagen, irgendwie habt ihr gegen das Parteiprogramm verstoßen.
Nee, bloß ich glaube schon, dass das Parteiprogramm einer Partei durchaus den, wie auch immer entstandenen, innerparteilichen Konsens abbildet. So ja, also ob der jetzt nun irgendwie gemanagte Demokratie oder Demokratie oder irgendwie Diktatur ist, wie auch immer der entstanden ist innerhalb dieser Partei, bildet der quasi das Zielgerüst dieser Partei ab. Und an den Stellen, wo er total schwaflich und indifferent ist, ist die Partei offensichtlich nicht einer Meinung. An den Stellen, wo er eher so ein bisschen klarer und irgendwie fassbarer ist, ist die Partei offensichtlich ungefähr dieser Meinung. Und wenn du dir da halt irgendwie das AfD-Parteiprogramm anguckst, ist das halt schon an vielen Stellen eine brutale Mischung aus ultra-neoliberalem Scheiß und sozialem Konservatismus, den wir seit irgendwie den 70er Jahren in der CSU so nicht mehr gesehen haben.
Also die Bertelsmann Stiftung Partei, inhaltlich war mein Eindruck.
In der Wirtschaftspolitik ja. In der Wirtschaftspolitik ja. In der Sozialpolitik ist das halt eher unklar.
Ich glaube, die haben in der Wirtschaft sich einfach keine Gedanken gemacht und haben halt übernommen, was der erste Lobbyist gesagt hat.
Genau. Ich glaube nämlich, dass sie da halt einfach, weil die haben ja dieses Kompetenzvermutungsproblem, dass sie halt irgendwie, da sind die, also die Leute, die tatsächlich Ahnung hatten, nämlich die Professoren, sind ja mit dem Lücke damals gegangen. Und, also Ahnung, also zumindest, die wissen das Feldkanten, um es mal irgendwie neutral zu formulieren, die sind ja mit dem Lücke damals gegangen und, Lücke, und der Rest, der jetzt dageblieben ist, naja, die waren halt sehr einfach zu beeinflussen. So lange der Kern der Partei, nämlich halt die Fremdenfeindlichkeit und das System kaputt machen, was ja so, also das sind ja so die beiden, die beiden Kerne, so lange die nicht angetastet werden, kann man da im Rest reinschreiben und tun lassen, was man will.
Ja, du hast auch meinen Eindruck. Ich glaube, dass die Fremdenfeindlichkeit kein Kernwert der AfD ist, sondern dass das eher ein Symptom dafür ist, dass wenn sich Leute ungerecht behandelt fühlen, dann geht's los gegen die Ausländer. Denn in Zeiten, wo es in der Bundesrepublik immer schön Wachstum und Arbeitsplätze für alle gab, gab es zwar auch so ein Grundrauschen, aber dass das irgendwie als Problem angesprochen wird. Das passiert erst, entweder wenn es richtig viele Ausländer werden, also so als damals die Türken vermehrt kamen, gab es plötzlich so ein Gefühl, was ich auch hab, wenn ich in Berlin U-Bahn fahre. Jeder zweite, den du reden hörst, ist entweder französisch oder englisch oder so. Und das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass es auf manche Leute bedrohlich wirkt, wenn Leute da in irgendwelchen Sprachen reden, die sie nicht verstehen am besten noch. Dieses Gefühl, in seinem eigenen Land nicht mehr die Mehrheit zu bilden, das ist eine tiefe Angst bei vielen Leuten. Das kann man auch nicht einfach wegwischen. Aber ich halte es trotzdem für ein Symptom. Denn solange es dir gut geht und du nicht das Gefühl hast, du könntest irgendwie deinen Arbeitsplatz verlieren. Weil irgendwelche Leute, die den streitig machen können, das sind alles Sachen, die eh schon kaputt sein müssen, damit du dich auf die Ausländer kaprizierst. Das ist mein Eindruck. Und ich glaube, es gibt zwar in der AfD viele Leute, die gegen Ausländer sind, aber nicht, weil sie generell gegen Ausländer sind, sondern weil sie einfach andere Probleme haben, und es jetzt auf die Ausländer projizieren.
Na, ich glaube, da machst du das jetzt so einfach. Also zum ersten ist der Rassismus, den die AfD pflegt, ist ja kein platter alter Rassismus mehr, zumindest nicht im Parteiprogramm. Viele von ihren Mitgliedern und Sympathisanten tun das immer noch. Aber die Krantese, die die modernen rechtsradikalen Nazis benutzen, ist der Ethnopluralismus. Und der funktioniert so, dass sie sagen...
Und diese Identitären meinst du jetzt?
Das geht bei allen durch. Die Identitären sind da ziemlich weit vorne theoretisch, aber da kommt das Konzept her, aber das haben mittlerweile alle übernommen. Und das Konzept sagt halt so, wir sind dafür, dass es irgendwie viele Völker, viele Ethnien, viele Kulturkreise gibt auf diesem Planeten, aber jeder da, wo er ist.
Auch bei uns ist es okay, solange sie blond und blau irgendwie sind.
Also sozusagen den Rassismus von der Rasse, von dieser Rassentheorie lösen und sagen so, das ist quasi ein kultureller Rassismus. Und die Argumente, die daraus abgeleitet werden, sind natürlich total anschlussfähig. Die sagen halt, naja, die haben jetzt halt ihre Länder verkackt. Da ist halt Krieg und Mord und Totschlag. Und jetzt kommen sie hierher.
Den wir ja dahingetragen haben, wenn ich das mal am Reiter erwähnen darf.
Den wir dahingetragen haben, ist sozusagen...
Und wir haben ihnen die Waffen verkauft.
Mach jetzt mal gerade den Argument, kurz nicht kaputt. Das kommt ja da. Aber die haben ihre Länder nicht auf die Reihe bekommen. Die haben kein Wirtschaftswachstum usw. Und jetzt kommen sie zu uns und machen unsere Länder kaputt. Und unsere Aufgabe, so wie diese etnapluralistischen Theoretiker, ist halt dafür zu sorgen, dass das nicht passiert. Das lässt sich halt nur durch Begrenzung von Einwanderung erzielen. So, diese These ist halt eine völlig andere als Schwarze sind dumm. Also das ist viel Anschlussfähiger, weil die meisten Menschen mit einem halbwegs westeuropäisch-humanitären Weltbild möchten eigentlich nicht zugeben, dass sie möglicherweise irgendwie Rassisten sind. Das wollen sie halt eigentlich nicht. Das gehört nicht zum guten Ton. Das ist halt irgendwie doof. Das haben wir lange genug gehabt, Sklaverei usw.
Ja, Moment, aber was zum guten Ton gehört, ist zum Beispiel, sich dafür einzusetzen, dass valisisch nicht ausstirbt, ja? Und dann zu sagen, das ist ein erhaltenswertes Kulturgut. Und wenn du dann nämlich dich einmal darauf committet hast, dass du Kulturgüter erhaltenswert findest, dann ist auch die Rhetorik plötzlich viel besser zu sagen, unsere Kulturgüter sind aber in Gefahr, weil wir hier gerade überrannt werden. Das heißt, du kannst sie an ihren Werten packen, sozusagen, also nicht irgendwie subjektiv an ihren Werten packen. Nennen wir es mal so.
Naja, das Problem dabei ist natürlich, dass das Argument der Politik, also der etablierten Parteien, ist ja eigentlich nur ein Globalisierungsargument. Nämlich zu sagen, die Welt ist jetzt so.
Ein wirtschaftliches Argument vor allem, ne?
Na, das ist eine Erweiterung des wirtschaftlichen Arguments. Also das ist halt so, wenn du sagst, okay, wir haben irgendwie quasi freien Verkehr von Waren, von Kapital, von Ideen, von Informationen.
Und von Menschen, aber nur in der EU.
Und eben nicht von Menschen, außerhalb der EU. Und auch innerhalb der EU.
Ja, aber das ist ja der zentrale Punkt bei den Dynähtitären auch zu sagen, innerhalb der EU ist es schon okay, wenn die Leute sich frei bewegen dürfen, aber dann dürfen aber nicht von außen irgendwie Leute reinkommen.
Nicht bei den Syndiondromer, weil die sind gehörne eigentlich dazu.
Ja, aber das ist ja nun, ja.
Das ist ja so der Argument. Der Punkt dabei ist natürlich auch ein großes Versammlungs der Politik, weil wie erklärt man denn nun, also dass diese Globalisierung an sich, also diese wir sind eine Welt und wollen halt einen möglichst freien, dass alle Güterströme, alle Kapital und so weiter sich frei bewegen kann, aber nicht die Menschen. Das ist ja sozusagen so, das ist quasi der...
Einen Spruch haben sie noch nicht in der Anstalt gehabt. Der war absolut großartig, wie war denn das? Sichere Transportwege gibt es bei uns nur für Güter, nicht für Menschen.
Genau.
Das ist ja der zentrale Punkt eigentlich.
Das ist der zentrale Punkt.
Wir setzen die Bundeswehr ein, um irgendwie die Küsten vor Somalia freizubomben, aber nicht damit die Leute besser fliehen können, sondern damit unsere Transporter durchkommen.
Genau, damit die Schiffe da lang fahren können. Und das ist natürlich so ein Ding, wenn es kombiniert ist mit so einer diffusen Furcht vor Überfremdung, dann entsteht daraus natürlich so eine Mischung, wo die sagen, ich bin doch gar kein Rassist. Ich hab doch nichts dagegen, ich geh natürlich mit einem Döner beim Türken essen. Da bin ich gerne, der mag mich. So, deshalb mit dem unterhalte ich mich gerne. Wir haben sogar politisch dieselben Meinungen. So, weil der ist halt auch ein bisschen konservativer. Also ich hab kein Problem damit.
Das richtig Krasse ist ja, dass die unter den AfD-Anhängern sehr gut vertreten sind auch die Einwanderer der ersten Generation, die nämlich hergekommen sind, haben sich hier integriert und sagen ja, aber haben wir diese ganzen anderen Leute. Und das ist natürlich auch eine Sache, mit dem man sich mal argumentativ auseinandersetzen müsste. Weil das ist natürlich erst recht, ein Argument für die AfD zu sagen, dann kann es doch kein Rassismus sein, wenn der auch dafür ist. Aber da hat ja noch keiner was gegen das Argument gesagt. Das wird nicht mal irgendwie in den Diskurs aufgenommen.
Also im amerikanischen Diskurs gibt es da einen Namen für das, der Othering.
Das ist aber noch ein bisschen was anderes, oder? Das ist, wenn du sagst In-Group und Out-Group und sagst, das sind aber die anderen.
Ja, aber so funktioniert es ja genau an der Stelle. Nämlich die anderen sind halt die, die noch nicht lange genug da sind, um irgendwie so zu tun, als wären sie assimiliert. Und das Politikargument, was dagegen gebracht wird, ist momentan ja nicht darüber zu reden.
Na und du willst ja auch eigentlich gar nicht, dass die sich assimilieren. Das finde ich nämlich den interessanten Teil bei der AfD, dass die auf der einen Seite sagt, wir haben ja nichts gegen Leute, die sich assimilieren. Auf der anderen Seite willst du aber niemandem die Chance geben, sich zu assimilieren, weil du nämlich eigentlich hat das mit Assimilieren nichts zu tun, das ist nur der Talking Point. Du willst eigentlich nicht, dass die jetzt alle kommen und sich dann anstrengen und sich hier schön integrieren, denn du hast ja fundamental was gegen die. Das ist so eine Bruchstelle bei denen im Moment, wo man eigentlich mal so einen Hebel reintun könnte.
Wo man tatsächlich ansetzen könnte, wenn man halt irgendwie mal...
Wenn es jemand versuchen würde.
Wenn Politik halt nicht für den großen Fehler der Linken halte, dass sie halt zu lange diese Gedankenwelt nur versucht haben, durch Ausgrenzung zu bekämpfen. Und das war halt ein großer Fehler. Weil man hätte sehr viel früher anfangen müssen, nicht irgendwie weiter auf diesem No-Platforming-Bullshit hängen zu bleiben und zu sagen, so pass auf, wir wollen versuchen, dass die nicht groß werden. Und dazu müssen wir sie intellektuell angreifen. Wir müssen Antworten haben auf die Fragen, die die stellen. Und auch wenn die Fragen zum Teil Bullshit sind, dann muss man trotzdem darauf achten.
Gerade dann musst du Antworten haben.
Ja, musst halt Antworten haben, die halt nicht sind.
Du bist doof.
Die Welt ist jetzt halt so globalisiert. Weil, meine Worte, die wir jetzt ja haben, ist ja zum Beispiel in Ungarn, diese Worte, die Oran tut, ist ja auch sehr interessant, wenn man dessen, sagen wir, liest so. Weißt du, an dessen frühe Reden insbesondere, also bevor er als an die Macht gekommen ist, was er getan hat, war, er hat die Verbindung hergestellt zwischen der gescheiterten liberalen Globalisierung, also gescheitert 2008 Finanzkrise und liberalen Werten, also liberalen bürgerlichen Werten von Freiheit, irgendwie Freizügigkeit und so weiter und so fort gesagt.
Universielle Menschenrichtung.
Und hat halt gesagt, das war ein Fehler. Diese Globalisierung hat uns nur angelogen und unsere Arbeitsplätze gekostet und sind in diese Finanzkrise gestürzt. Und demzufolge sind auch die Werte, die damit zusammenhängen. Also quasi diese Hochzeit von irgendwie bürgerlichen Werten und Kapitalismus sind offensichtlich auch ein Problem. So, weil die haben uns dahin gebracht. Das ist halt so diese, also es ist eine Invariante von diesem Westdeutschen, die versifften 68er haben das System korrumpiert. Also das hat so, die Hippies haben halt irgendwie alles kaputt gemacht mit ihrem Multikulti-Liberalismus.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch inhaltlich nicht völlig abwegig, der Gedankengang. Was sind denn die Gegenargumente? Was bringen denn die anderen Parteien dagegen?
Nein, sie bringen nichts dagegen.
Es gibt nichts dagegen, das ist natürlich toll.
Sie bringen halt nichts dagegen, weil sie diesen Junctum herzustellen, zu sagen, die Finanzkrise, also die Exzesse des Kapitalismus, sind eine logische Folge seiner Werte. Führt halt natürlich direkt in eine gemanagte Demokratie aller China. Weil du sagst, okay, wir müssen halt irgendwie für eine stabile Gesellschaft sorgen, wir wollen halt eine wertebasierte, sozusagen wie auch immer diese Werte aussehen, nämlich sozial-konservative Gesellschaft.
Also bei Werten werde ich immer ganz vorsichtig in letzter Zeit, weil das immer so ein Begriff ist, der von irgendwelchen rechtskonservativen Arschlöchern kommt, die immer nur nicht sagen wollen, was denn ihre Werte sind, weil die nämlich rassistisch werden.
Wenn du das dann halt hinterfragst, dann wird es halt ganz schnell ziemlich doll rassistisch. Genau. Das ist halt genau dieser Punkt, also wo die Politik momentan schon wieder in diesem Ding ist, dass sie sagt, okay, wir wollen uns damit nicht inhaltlich auseinandersetzen. Zu jenemassen ist es auch schwer, weil die natürlich, also die inhaltlich auseinandersetzen, wenn du auf die Parteiprogramm nimmst, wäre das halt total trivial. Dann könnte man sagen, Entschuldigung hier, was soll diese liberale Kackscheiße hier, davon wollen wir nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Die vertritt ja die CDU auch, dann können sie ja nicht dagegen sein.
Also da gibt es halt genügend in der CDU, die sagt, also die Arbeitslosenversicherung ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so eine gute Idee, die kann man doch privatisieren. Dann findest du genau Leute in der CDU, dann ist Pd vielleicht weniger, aber meint. So und aus meiner Sicht ist die Ursünde dabei, ist diese Agenda 2010.
Weil, sag mal, kann es sein, dass die deswegen auch nicht sagen können, weil sie dann erklären müssten, was sonst schuld war an der Finanzkrise und das ist ein Thema, weil sie nicht ansprechen können, weil sie nämlich schuld waren?
Das ist natürlich ein Regulierungsfehler.
Nee, aber ich mein, meinst du, dass auch der Grund ist, warum die da nicht gegenhalten im Moment?
Ich glaube, dass das Ideenvakuum in der Politik gerade hat damit zu tun, dass die so ein bisschen Schockstar davor sind, dass es jetzt einfach Bürger gibt, die da draußen sagen so, ich will halt nur das System brennen sehen, weil alles ist besser als jetzt irgendwie weiter mit Hartz IV rumkrepeln oder die Aussicht darauf haben, das zu verlieren.
Das ist eigentlich auch die hauptkorridierende Wirkung von Lügenpresse, dass du einfach sagst, das ganze System ist scheiße, nicht nur das Medium, das Medium, die Zeitung.
Das ist alles.
Das ist alles scheiße. Und das ist auch eine Sache, wo irgendwie keiner was... Wenn du sagst, das System ist scheiße, dann meint das ja nicht nur die Presse.
Genau. Und wenn du halt was dagegen sagst, gehörst du automatisch zum System.
Natürlich.
Das ist ja so.
Versteht sich vor selbst.
Und das Interessante ist, dass man genau dieselbe Argumentationslinie findest du in den Nazi-Zeitungen aus den Anfang der 30ern.
Und die Linken operieren ja genauso. Wenn du da kommst und irgendwie anfängst, Fundamentale Oppositionen gegen irgendein Detailproblem zu machen, bist du auch sofort Teil des Systems. Nazi-Sympathisanten. Na, aber hallo.
Ja, also je nachdem von welcher Ecke du redest. Ja, also wenn du bei den antideutschen Landen bist, dann sicherlich ja. Aber interessant daran ist halt eben, dass diese Argumentation mit diesem Das-System, also meistens dann noch mit dem Adjektiv plutokratisch davor war das dann bei den Nazis exakt genau die selbe Argumentation.
Und das stimmt ja inhaltlich. Das ist ja das Schlimme, dass die Begriffe nicht irgendwie, das sind halt die Begriffe, die du nehmen würdest, um diesen Punkt auszusprechen. Die haben ja nicht neue Wörter erfunden, sondern das sind ja genau, also du kannst, das ist ein breiträumig, haben die Fachbegriffe verbrannt.
Ja, genau, man kann halt nicht mehr darüber reden.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch total scheiße.
Wenn ich mir jetzt halt zum Beispiel diese Nummer halt mit Kalifornien angucke, also mit dieser demokratischen Partei da, wenn die so einen Stunt bringen, ist es halt schwer von was anderem als dem System zu reden.
Demokratie 2.0. Na, wir können auch nur irgendwie neue Begriffe dafür finden.
So, und die Frage halt, was man dagegen tut, also wie halt irgendwie eine sinnvolle Opposition gegen dieses, also auf der einen Seite halt dieses, naja, diese Ideenlosigkeit innerhalb der etablierten Politik und auf der anderen Seite diesen ich will das System brennen sehen Ding ist halt gerade fatal.
Vielleicht muss man das System aufsplitten. Wenn ich vom System rede, meine ich ja nicht die Menschen, sondern ich meine so das Regelwerk und die Anreize, die Anreizstruktur, die gesetzt werden. Genau. Aber das heißt ja, das ist ja ein Unterschied, wenn ich sage, wenn ich irgendwie alle die Leute auch meine. Also wenn ich irgendwie anfange, das System zu kritisieren, dann sage ich der Typ, der das gerade macht, der kann gar nicht anders, weil die Struktur ist so, dass er in seiner Position macht man das genauso halt. Und das ist ja sozusagen ein Argument dagegen, gegen die Personen irgendwie zu sein, weil ich sage, die kann gar nicht anders.
Also ich glaube, dass der Ausweg ist tatsächlich eine positive Utopie. Wie auch immer die positive Utopie aussieht, aber ich glaube der Ausweg kann nur eine positive Utopie sein und die muss meines Erachtens von der Linken kommen, weil das Problem ist auf der konservativen Seite, sind die Sympathien mit dieser AfD-Art zu denken, so diese Fremdenfeindlichkeit, dieses, wenn man halt so Don Alfonso liest, dieses irgendwie alles außer Bayern ist scheiße. Das ist halt sehr nah dran. Also das ist halt so eine, also nicht so extrem und nicht so...
Das habe ich völlig vergessen. Ich habe mir am Anfang die These aufgestellt, dass uns das Fundament gerade wegbröselt. Der Sachen, die wir für Teile irgendwie für Selbstverständlichkeiten, auch der Länderfinanzausgleich ist gerade gekippt, wo auch völlig unklar ist, was jetzt anders wird. Also die Strukturen, die ich seit meiner Kindheit kannte, sind plötzlich weg. Diese ganze Rhetorik fällt auch plötzlich weg. Bayern ist ja immer das Geberland, was den Rest der maroden Berlin vor allem finanziert. Das ist seit vielen Jahren die Rhetorik der CSU und da ist ja auch was dran. Was wird denn da jetzt? Also viele Sachen, an die man sich so gewöhnt hat, werden jetzt ersetzt durch irgendwie, ja keiner weiß, was da jetzt genau passieren soll.
Okay, wenn man das jetzt zusammennimmt, dann heißt es ja, dass das Thema eigentlich schon brennt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das ist doch mein Eindruck. Sonst würden wir diese ganze Festung Europa-Geschichte nicht machen. Ich meine, die EU würde doch keine Leute im Mittelmeer ersaufen lassen, wenn sie nicht das Gefühl hätte, das geht nicht anders. Wir sind schon seit ein paar Jahren im Verzweiflungsmodus, aber wir haben es nicht an die Leute weiter kommuniziert, sondern das ist halt nur die Bürokraten oben. Und deswegen kommen wir auch nicht weiter, weil die alle glauben, das muss so. Das ist jetzt hier Notstand. Das ist wie mit Frankreich, die auch ihre Notstandsgesetze dann immer verlängern. Alle halbe Jahr, oder was da der Ablauf ist. Ich glaube, die EU ist seit einer Weile in genau dem Boden. Und deswegen kriegen wir da auch nicht mehr Demokratie. Weil die glauben, wir müssen jetzt durch diese Krise durch. Und danach können wir über alles reden. Aber bis dahin ist jetzt hier Notstand.
Das ist das, was ich damals mit Robin, die wir das zuvor beschrieben haben. Die denke, das wird ja sich in den betreuten Bürokraten so.
Scheiße, wir brauchen doch irgendein positiver Aspekt in dieser Sendung. Sonst brechen uns hier die Hörer weg. Die Selbstmordrate ging nach oben in Deutschland.
Naja, wenn man sich anguckt, was gibt es denn so an Widerstand oder Alternativen so? Ich meine, Wikileaks hat ja angefangen.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal anfangen, uns eine Utopie auszumalen. Was schwebt dir denn davor?
Warte mal, ich will noch ganz kurz diese Wikileaks nochmal machen. Weil das fand ich ja gerade sehr interessant, dass irgendwie der, was Wikileaks ja da gerade tut, gut mit dem Trump Support, weil sie irgendwie auf gar keinen Fall wollen, dass Hillary irgendwie drankommt, weil Hillary hat nun wirklich alle Gründe halt dafür zu sorgen, dass irgendwie Julian wirklich gedroht wird, die, also wenn es mal von diesem Extremen absieht, dass sie sich wirklich auf eine Seite schlagen und mittlerweile sogar Trump Merchandise in ihrem Shop verkaufen. Wie war das?
Also das hat mir jemand per Mail erklärt, dass dieser Shop sozusagen semi-automatisch von der Community betrieben wird und es folgt aus Forenwahlen, was da angeboten wird. Das kann man jetzt gerade nicht Julian irgendwie anlasten. Dies eine Sache kann man nicht Julian anbassen.
Das weiß ich diese nicht. Aber okay. Aber interessant ist halt diese, wenn man so alte Blogposts von ihm liest, hat er ja 2006 quasi schon mal gesagt, was er eigentlich machen will. Und der sagt halt irgendwie, je mehr Geheimhaltung und Ungerechtigkeit eine Organisation beinhalten, umso anfälliger ist sie für Leaks. Also umso mehr werden diese Leaks zu furcht und Paranoia führen.
Gut, das stimmt natürlich.
Und das führt dazu, dass wenn es Leaks gibt, wie jetzt gerade über die Demokraten, wird diese Organisation automatisch ineffizienter, weil sie dann halt irgendwie Off-Hit-E-Mail zu benutzen, weil sie irgendwie sich mit Krypto und sicherer Kommunikation beschäftigen muss, weil sie Angst hat, Dinge zu dokumentieren. Und er nennt das die Secrecy-Tags.
Weißt du, für wen das eine tolle Story wäre? Adam Curtis. Ich kann mir so richtig vorstellen, wie Adam Curtis aus der Prämisse so eine Kunstwerkschaft.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber interessant ist halt ja, dass diese Idee zu sagen...
Secrecy ist selbst korrumpierend.
Die Leaks dienen halt nicht mehr unbedingt nur der Transparenz, sondern die sind tatsächlich eine politische Waffe, die halt eingesetzt werden gegen Organisationen, die was zu verbergen haben. Also das ist ja diese Grundidee dabei. Die ist halt bisher verkannt worden, glaube ich. Die ist halt bisher noch nicht so richtig im Bewusstsein angekommen. Und wir sehen das, glaube ich, jetzt gerade bei den Demokraten. Weil da gibt es allerhand Berichte darüber, dass die jetzt halt anfangen, halt irgendwie ihre E-Mail-Accounts zu löschen oder zu cleanen und irgendwie, dass sie irgendwie alle nur noch irgendwie mit Dampfhunds rumlaufen und so.
Ja, weißt du, wer das verstanden hat? Ist der Verfassungsschutz. Die haben sehr gezielt genau die Akten vernichtet, die peinlich gewesen wurden. Übrigens, lustiges Detail am Rande, weil du hier von Sci-Fi und Utopie redest. Es gibt eine Sci-Fi-Utopie von einer Art WikiLeaks, die aber nicht der Öffentlichkeit dient, sondern immer meistbietend versteigert. Und aber so versteigert, dass nie jemand einen Vorteil hat. Und diese Utopie kommt aus dem Mass-Effect-Spiel und heißt Shadow Broker.
Die Shadow Broker, ja.
Und genau nach dieser Utopie haben sich jetzt die Leute benannt, die diese NSA-Mailware versteigern. Das ist schon alles sehr... Eigentlich kommt einem das fast vor wie so ein Buchplot gerade, oder? Den irgendwie jemand sitzt irgendwo...
Das ist aber echt ein wilder Plot. Ja, aber ich meine...
Es wirkt, weißt du, es gibt hier diese ganzen mehr oder weniger spurious irgendwie Zusammenhänge und ich stell mir immer vor, dass irgendwo einer sitzt in seinem Armsessel, weißt du, vor dem Kamin und reibt sich jedes Mal die Hände, wenn ein weiteres Detail von seinem Masterplan irgendwie von irgendjemandem verstanden wird.
Na gut, aber gut, kurz diesen Bogen zurückzumachen. Ist das ja auch eine Invariante von, ich will das System brennen sehen? Na klar. Und um jetzt wieder auf die Utopie zurückzukommen, ist natürlich die große Frage, was passiert dann?
Na eigentlich ist es doch die Ansage, das System wird von ganz alleine brennen, solange die immer mehr secrecy fahren. Und das kann man ja auch ein bisschen beobachten, ganz unabhängig von Wikileaks, dass wir jetzt diesen ganzen NSU-Aufklärungsausschuss überhaupt haben. Der hat ja auch Schaden angerichtet. Bei den Dienst, der gar nicht reparabel ist, die haben sich da teilweise im Kopf und Kragen geredet. Das hat sich sicher auch keiner von denen jemals vorgestellt, dass sie da für einen Scheißausschuss zitiert werden und dann befragt werden. Aber da siehst du auch so richtig, was sich da für Metastasen bilden, wenn da nie jemand rumliegt. Also insofern würde ich dem Julian da durchaus recht geben. Das wird nicht besser. Secrecy macht alles nur schlimmer. Und dann braucht das immer mehr Kohle, um zu überleben. Und irgendwann bist du bei der NSA, die halt irgendwie ein unglaubliches schwarzes Budget hat und davon vor allem irgendwelche bekloppten Geheimhaltungslevel finanziert.
Naja, und dann, also man muss ja irgendwie immer hinzugestehen, dass irgendwie Hillary als Politikerin ist ja schon ganz gut. So, also das ist jetzt irgendwie so im Sinne von Handwerk.
Ach so, du meinst, naja, gut. Sie kennt die Mechanismen.
Naja, und ich meine, sie hat...
Im Vergleich zu Trump sehen aber alle gut aus, wenn ich hier mal kurz zu Protokoll gebe.
Aber interessant daran war, dass hier in den geleakten Vorträgen gibt es einen interessanten Punkt, also der nur an...
Realitätsmanagement. Wir müssen eine andere Realität innen und außen pflegen. Den meinst du, oder?
Genau, und das Argument danach, was sie sozusagen als Pro-Point dafür gebracht hat, hast du es mitbekommen?
Nee.
Er hat gesagt, naja, damals als die Sklaverei abgeschafft wurde, hat es nur funktioniert, weil Abraham Lincoln irgendwelchen Backbencher-Senat waren von der Gegenseite, irgendwelche Backroom-Deals und Geschäfte und Jobs und so versprochen hat, damit die für die Abschaffung der Sklaverei stimmen. Und nur deswegen ist die Sklaverei damals abgeschafft worden.
Nun ja.
So, da kann man wahrscheinlich wissen, oder? Da muss aber hinzugestehen, dass in dieser non-linearen Realität, in diesem Weltbild von...
Politik muss stinken und schmutzig sein, sonst wirkt sie nicht.
Genau. Das ist halt schon sehr spannend zu beobachten.
Ja, nun ist die Hillary halt eine fiese Kriegstreiberin. Das kann man echt nicht anders sagen. Und ich fürchte, wenn die Präsidentin wird, dann werden wir noch viel mehr Drohnenkriege haben. Und irgendwelche armen Blinder werden weiter bombadiert.
Wenn Trump Präsident wird, wird auch genau dasselbe passieren.
Na, da bin ich mir nicht sicher. Ich glaube, der ist zu sehr wirtschaftlich. Das Problem ist, ich meine, Kriege kosten Kohle. Und ich weiß nicht, ob der so ein Typ ist, der Wirtschaftsförderung betreiben würde.
Nee, aber Trump ist...
Ich glaube, der ist eher so ein Typ, der sagt, ja, wenn du nur mit Förderung überlebst, dann schneide ich dich lieber raus und nehme das als Profit mit.
Aber Trump ist im Prinzip hier eigentlich Pleite und daraus resultiert, dass...
Man ist erst anfällig für...
Wenn da Lockheed Martin hingeht und sagt so, ach wissen Sie, Herr Präsident.
Ey, Lockheed Martin, du, ich bin ja gerade beim Fnordmeldung sortieren und dieses Jahr gab es die eine Meldung, dass bei der Air Force die Datenbank mit den ganzen Korruptionsfällen und den Unterlagen dazu verloren gegangen ist, durch einen bedauerlichen Computerfehler. Und den hat die Air Force outgesourct an Lockheed Martin. Und wenn du dich jetzt fragst, wer wahrscheinlich Korruptionsfälle bei der Air Force betreiben würde.
Das ist ja bedauerlicher Datenschäden. Guck, aber da gibt es in den Schuhen, gibt es da Chinese Walls, wo die eine Teilfirma hat nichts mit dem anderen Teil der Firma zu tun.
Na klar.
Also da achten die ganz sorgfältig drauf und das Compliance-Department wird auf jeden Fall dafür sorgen, dass sowas auf gar keinen Fall passiert. Kennen wir schon aus der Bankenkrise, dass das ganz hervorragend funktioniert hat.
Eigentlich haben wir ja noch eine lange Liste zu TTIP. Wollen wir das noch machen?
Das war so deprimierend.
Ja, das ist alles deprimierend, aber ich glaube, wir müssen nochmal durch, weil das gerade brennt. Also jetzt nicht TTIP, sondern CETA.
Ja, ich meine, CETA ist ja irgendwie ein sehr interessanter Fall. Die Kanadier haben ja jetzt einen hochattraktiven Premierminister, der insbesondere die ganzen Hillary-Fangirls in Deutschland irgendwie stehen.
Geniale, macklige Knie, wenn sie sein Bild sehen.
Sie stehen ja total auf den. Und deswegen wird CETA da halt auch tatsächlich nicht so hart angegriffen wie TTIP interessanterweise, weil der Trudeau halt ja durchaus...
Ach, der sieht so gut aus.
Der sieht so gut aus und ist so charmant. Genau, der macht halt auch nichts Böses. Also der hat halt irgendwie so dieses Robbenbaby...
Du, ich glaube, dass das auch so ein bisschen dieses PC-Zeug ist, wenn er dich ein paar Mal... Also das eignet sich halt hervorragend zum signalisieren von Werten und von In-Group-Zugehörigkeit. Und der Trudeau hat am Anfang halt ein paar so eine Aktion gemacht. Unter anderem seine Parlamentsaufteilung ist ja nun wirklich irgendwie 50 Prozent fraubütlich. Und als er gefragt wurde, meinte er dann so... Also warum? Er ist gefragt worden, warum? Dann meinte er nur, weil 2016 ist. Und das war eine brillante Antwort. Seitdem ist klar, der ist auf der richtigen Seite. Und ich glaube, wenn so funktioniert eben dieses Wertesignaling, dass man ihm jetzt die anderen Sachen halt abnimmt, das ist ja halt auf der... Der wird schon auf der richtigen Seite sein.
Genau, weil hat er die eine so richtig gemacht, der kann dann so...
Der ist jetzt auf der richtigen Seite. Und dem verzeiht man dann. Was ja auch ein gefährlicher Mechanismus eigentlich ist. Naja, also ich glaube auch nicht, dass Trudeau da jetzt irgendwie schuld an irgendwas ist. Der kam so spät dazu, der muss jetzt halt...
Der vertrete halt die Interessen seines Landes.
Ja, aber der ist auch an den ganzen Beratungen gar nicht beteiligt gewesen. Die laufen ja seit Jahren, verhandeln die da vor sich hin.
Dem werden halt die Industrieverbinder gesagt haben, wir wollen das jetzt und dann macht er das halt.
Genau, du machst das jetzt. Und dann macht er das halt. Das ist ja wie bei uns halt. Die Merkel macht ja auch nicht TTIP und CETA, weil sie gerne TTIP und CETA machen will. Aber es gibt halt, ich hab mich mit ein paar Leuten drüber unterhalten und war halt schockiert, was da für Argumente kamen für TTIP und CETA. Also durchaus von Linken. Ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Neokons. Von Neokons kommen so Argumente wie, das ist gut für die Wirtschaft, die europäische Wirtschaft wird um 0,5 Prozent wachsen und pro Europäer macht es durchschnittlich 530 Dollar oder Euro an Reichtum. Die werden dann ausgeschüttet. Das ist so die Implikation, was natürlich Bullshit ist. Das landet dann bei den irgendwie 0,1 Prozent und der Rest geht leer aus, wie immer. Aber also dieser Art von Argument kommt von den Neokons. Aber die haben es geschafft, mit ihren Argumenten auch die Linken zu unterwandern. Und die Argumente auf der Seite sind auch ganz spannend. Und ich finde es zumindest Teil unseres Bildungsauftrags, die mal anzusprechen. Und eines der Argumente ist, naja, aber dann können wir ja Mindeststandards setzen.
Mindeststandards, ok.
Ja, also die Argumentation geht so, dass wir sagen, ok, wenn wir jetzt TTIP machen und CETA, dann haben wir zusammen über 50 Prozent des Wirtschaftsraums der Welt. Und dann haben wir genug Druck, um den anderen gegenüber unsere Mindeststandards durchzusetzen. Und die Mindeststandards, sie könnten dann so was sein wie Mindestlohn oder keine Sweatshops mehr, so das ist so die Argumentation. Und da musst du dich natürlich fragen, warum sollten die denn dann auf uns hören? Wir haben jetzt auch schon 50 Prozent ohne TTIP. Wenn wir das wollten, könnten wir das auch jetzt schon. Wollen wir aber nicht, weil dann wird es nämlich teurer.
Na und, also entspricht das denn der Wahrheit?
Das ist das nächste Problem. Ja, bei den Mindeststandards, die sind dann nämlich für alle Jahre festgeschrieben. Denn TTIP und CETA sehen vor, dass es Schiedsgerichte gibt, vor denen eine Firma dann gegen eine Regierung klagen kann, wenn sich ihr wirtschaftliches Umfeld durch eine Handlung dieser Regierung negativ entwickelt. Also das könnte zum Beispiel sein, dass jemand mehr als den Mindeststandard umsetzen will. Also wenn wir jetzt sagen, der Mindeststandard klingt ja schon so mindestmäßig, da können wir uns dann runterhandeln lassen, aber in der Praxis machen wir mehr. Das geht dann halt nicht mehr, ja, weil dieses Wir machen halt mehr treibt die Kosten hoch und dagegen können dann die Firmen klagen und können sich nicht nur ihre tatsächlichen entgangenen Gelder, die ja auch schon schwer nachzuweisen sind, entgangene Gelder, wie willst du das nachweisen, aber nicht nur die kannst du einklagen als Firma, sondern du kannst auch projizierte zukünftige wegfallende Einnahmen kannst du dir erstatten lassen. Das heißt, das ist eine reine Wunschveranstaltung. Ich möchte jetzt ein paar Milliarden haben. Und wenn wir das durch die Tür lassen, diese Regelungen, dann werden wir nie wieder mehr als die Mindeststandards haben, die wir jetzt verankern. Und die werden wahrscheinlich ein Kompromiss mit den Amerikanern oder Kanadiern sein, die da teilweise ganz andere Modelle fahren.
Das Kernproblem dabei ist, dass Europa hat ja als Regelungsgrundsatz das Precautionary Principle. Das heißt also, wenn irgendwas ein bisschen fies und komisch aussieht, dann reguliert man es lieber erst mal und guckt dann mal, wie es sich entwickelt. Na vor allem, wenn ich ein Produkt auf dem Markt regeln will. Und die Amerikaner haben das gegenteilige Prinzip, nämlich die sagen, wenn es jetzt erstmal nicht offensichtlich komisch aussieht und nicht schon auf der Liste von verbotenen Dingen ist, dann kannst du erst mal machen, was du willst. Und wenn sich dann halt irgendwie negative Effekte zeigen, regulieren wir hinterher.
Na und du kannst ja dann verklagt werden.
Genau, du kannst ja verklagt werden, also regulieren im Sinne von entweder...
Der Markt regelt das dann.
Der Markt regelt das dann. Ja, das ist halt so. Ja gut, nicht nur. Also ich meine, das gibt ja durchaus...
Ja, Kalifornien reguliert auch ganz gerne mal.
Genau. Aber selbst in Kalifornien ist das ja nicht precautionary. In Kalifornien ist halt nur, die sind halt nur schneller mit irgendwie mal hinterher draufschlagen.
Das ist aber nicht nur precautionary, sondern du musst, wenn du ein neues Produkt auf den Markt bringst, sozusagen die Ungefährlichkeit nachweisen, bevor du das überhaupt verkaufen darfst. Und das ist halt völlig inkompatibel mit dem US-System. Das heißt, wenn wir uns da irgendwo einigen, dann wird mit Sicherheit dieses Prinzip fallen müssen. Ja.
Und kann man halt schon hart für argumentieren, dass das sich eigentlich bewährt hat?
Ja, nicht nur hat sich es bewährt. Das ist auch so, dass bei den Amerikanern immer wieder irgendwelche Skandale, also ich sag jetzt mal Lebensmittel, weil die sind sehr auffällig, mit irgendwelchen Eko, die Bakterien gibt. Und da ist dann auch immer das Argument, naja, du kannst ja den Hersteller verklagen, nachdem du krank geworden bist. Ja, und ich würde gerne in einer Welt leben, wo ich lieber gar nicht erst krank werde, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Mir doch scheißegal, ob ich mir dann irgendeine Kohle zurückholen kann. Ich will gar nicht erst krank werden. Aber so das Verständnis ist halt ein völlig anderes, ne? Und diese ganzen Versprechen, dass da irgendwelche Wirtschaftswachstumsgeschichten laufen, das würde ich da achten. Diese ganzen Wachstumsmythen sind abgefrühstückt seit, weiß nicht, mindestens fünf bis zehn Jahren.
Na, seit fünf Jahren kann man sagen. Also 2008 ist es vorbei, hat sich erledigt.
Da würde ich jetzt nichts mehr drauf geben, wenn ihr da jetzt irgendwas behaupten. Na ja, 2008 ist auch schon wieder fast zehn Jahre her.
Na gut.
Die Zeit vergeht. Und dann heißt es ja, das schafft 1,1 Millionen Arbeitsplätze in den USA und zwei Millionen in den OECD-Staaten und in Deutschland davon irgendwie 180.000. So und jetzt kann man auf der einen Seite natürlich mal fragen, wo kommt denn diese Schätzung her? So das ist schon mal so ein bisschen, ich meine, wie heißt das so schön? Vorhersagen sind schwierig, besonders über die Zukunft. Also wenn man diese ganzen Vorhersagen, was alles toll ist, Wenn es passieren wird, mal ein bisschen genauer anguckt, dann sind das immer irgendwelche Billiglohn-Dinger, die dann natürlich entstehen. Das sind ja keine Jobs mit Substanz, aber das erzählen sie einem halt nicht. Ich fand es auch ganz wichtig, mal rauszufinden, es heißt ja mit mir, wir könnten irgendwelche Sachen exportieren, die wir im Moment nicht exportieren können. Also umgekehrt haben wir das schon thematisiert. Chlorhühnchen, das ist ja hier irgendwie angesprochen worden. Aber was ist denn, also übrigens Chlorhühnchen, ich weiß nicht, ob alle das überhaupt auf dem Radar haben, was da die Geschichte dahinter ist. Die Geschichte ist die, dass die USA das Konzept haben, dass du das Hühnchen sozusagen in unsterilen Umgebungen und auch mit Krankheiten und was züchtest. Und dann nachdem es tot ist, sterilisierst du die ganzen Keime weg, indem du das in Chlor kippst. Und in Europa ist der Ansatz, das soll aber bitte schon unter hygienischen Umständen leben. Das ist auch nicht immer erreicht. Also Europa ist bei weitem nicht vorbildlich hier. Aber zumindest haben wir einen anderen Ansatz als sagen, okay, wir waschen irgendwie die Kacke ab, in denen das hier stagniert hat und kippen da einmal irgendwie Desinfektionsmittel drüber und dann kann man das schon verkaufen. Also das verbirgt sich hinter Chlorhühnchen, dass die Amerikaner haben eben die Idee, naja, dann sterilisieren wir das halt weg und dann ist gut. Und das funktioniert halt in der Praxis nicht. Die haben ständig irgendwelche E. coli-Bakterien-Skandale. Also das verbirgt sich hinter Chlorhühnchen. Und diese Art von, dann darfst du das aber nicht verkaufen, wenn das nur nach Sterilisationen irgendwie von Menschen gegessen werden kann. Das würde halt fallen wahrscheinlich mit TTIP und CETA. Das verbirgt sich hinter diesen Chlorhühnchen. Da müssten wir dann mit leben. Natürlich gehen manipulierte Sachen. Das ist auch so eine Frage. Da hat die EU eher zurückhaltende Regelungen. Nicht zuletzt, weil die Bauern da keinen Bock drauf haben. Aber umgekehrt, ich hab mal versucht, herauszufinden, was für Produkte dann auf unserer Seite betroffen werden, die dann plötzlich wieder exportiert werden können in den USA. Und da gibt es tatsächlich auch Beispiele, nämlich Reh und Lammfleisch aus England. Da gibt es im Moment ein Verkaufsverbot seit 20 Jahren, seit der BSE-Krise.
Okay.
Und die durften die Briten dann wieder verkaufen nach den USA. Also so auf dem Niveau reden wir hier. Ja, da gibt es ja auch. Also auch die USA haben gelegentlich so Verkaufsdinger. Ein anderes Argument für TTIP ist ja, aber dann fallen ja die Zölle weg. Und das ist ja gut für den Handel.
Wie viel Zoll ist denn da eigentlich noch?
Ich würde, das finde ich, ist die falsche Frage. Die richtige Frage ist, wir haben die WIPO und die WTO. Und die WTO hat die eine Funktion, wenn Land A ein Zoll gegen Land B verhängt, dann darf Land B ein Zoll in gleicher Höhe gegen Land A verhängen. Das heißt, wenn da Zölle sind, kann man die auch jetzt schon wegmachen. Da spricht nichts dagegen und das andere Land macht dann einen anderen Zoll weg und dann ist wieder plus minus null. Das heißt, dieses Prinzip würde auch mit TTIP nicht wegfallen. Also diese Argumentation, wir haben jetzt zu viele Zölle und die kriegen wir nicht weg, das ist großer Bullshit. Die Zölle sind jetzt alle entweder aus gutem Grund da oder als Rache gegen irgendeinen anderen Zoll der Gegenseite. Wenn wir jetzt einen politischen Willen hätten, die wegzumachen, dann könnten wir das auch ohne TTIP einfach tun. Macht aber keiner, weil die nämlich einen Grund haben. Viele Zölle sind dazu da, Protektionismus zu haben, um die eigene Industrie zu schützen.
Oder halt irgendwie um Hau um Dumping von anderen Leitern zu verhindern.
Ja, oder selber Dumping zu machen. Also die EU subventioniert zum Beispiel Agrarprodukte groß und möchte die dann halt einen Butterberg und muss den irgendwie abbauen. Und die USA haben da einen Schutzzoll dagegen. Ist ja auch irgendwie einleuchtend. Die haben nämlich selber eine Agrarindustrie, die sie gerne subventionieren möchten. Und das ist auch ein Argument, warum man einen Zoll vor der WTO rechtfertigen kann, weil die andere Seite illegal subventioniert. Und das ist ein Kampf, den die EU und die USA seit vielen Jahren führen, weil die USA zum Beispiel gern ihren Maisanbau stark subventionieren wollen. Und die EU findet das ungerecht. Und die EU hat zum Beispiel eine Subvention, die die Amerikaner angegriffen haben auf Bananen aus ehemaligen Kolonien in der Südsee. Und die Amerikaner fanden das sei ein Markthindernis für Chiquita-Banana.
Ich südsee Karibik.
Karibik und haben dagegen geklagt. Und das ist also die Art von Streiterei, die da seit Jahren geführt wird. Kein einziger Zoll ist da und könnte mal eben weg, sondern die haben alle ihre Begründung. Also jetzt so zu tun, als wäre TTIP die einzige Hoffnung, diese Zölle wegzukriegen, ist unseriös in meinen Augen.
Auf der Metaebene sehe ich ja diese Abkommen, also gerade TTIP oder TPP auf der anderen Seite Richtung Asien, ist ja gerade so der aktuelle Versuch, halt so nochmal diese Globalisierungs, also wirtschaftliche Globalisierungsgeschichte halt nochmal...
Unhinterfragt.
Ja und auch irgendwie quasi nochmal so den, so einen Flock einzurammen, so bevor halt das System wirklich brennt.
Wobei ich ja spannend finde, dass sie aber diese Geheimhaltung machen, weil sie schon gemerkt haben, dass die Globalisierungsrhetorik nicht mehr funktioniert.
Genau.
Das wird der Hintergrund sein, oder?
Ja, spätestens seit Brexit ist es mit dieser Globalisierungsrhetorik auch... Also wenn du mit den Leuten redest, ich bin ja ganz viel unterwegs irgendwie, so in der Industrie und so und rede halt auch mit so Leuten, die in der Wirtschaft ein bisschen weiter oben sind und so. Und da ist so die allgemeine Stimmung ist halt so, ja, wir haben es verkackt. Also wir haben es halt nicht geschafft, die Leute mitzunehmen und den die Vorteile, die sie halt durch die Globalisierung haben, entsprechend so zu verteilen, dass ein Großteil der Leute der Meinung ist, dass es gut für sie ist. Also ich meine, das wäre ja durchaus möglich. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie unmöglich gewesen wäre, aber die sagen halt, also insbesondere im Westen, also in Entwicklungsländern kann es halt noch viel besser belegen, weil da geht es den Leuten halt durchaus besser. So wenn halt irgendwie ihre Wirtschaft irgendwie auch schon hat und die mehr Richtung Westen exportieren können und so weiter. Und halt Technologie und so weiter. Also diese ganze, ja, Verteidigung.
China hat einen phänomenalen Aufschwung. Da gibt es mehr Millionäre in Hongkong und in Shanghai.
Die Millionäre sind ja weniger wichtig als die Mittelschicht.
Aber die Millionäre kannst du leichter messen als die Mittelschicht.
Aber die allgemeine Stimmung, das ist halt so, ja, das haben wir wohl leider versemmelt. Und die haben aber keine Idee. Also die wissen nicht, was sie halt jetzt stattdessen tun sollen. Und deswegen sind die halt immer noch auf diesem Weiter-Sum-Modus.
Das ist ja auch nicht so einfach.
Also es ist halt so eine Abwesenheit einer Gerechtigkeits-Utopie.
Ich glaube auch, das ist so ein Effekt wie mit IBM, was wir in der IT seit vielen Jahren haben. Da gab es immer so den Spruch, nobody ever got fired for buying IBM. Das ist so der sichere Hafen, wenn du sicher sein willst, dass du nicht schuld bist, wenn es vor die Wand fährt, kaufst du Hardware von IBM. Und so ist das, glaube ich, auch mit Globalisierung bei Politikern. Wenn die Angst um ihre Karriere haben, der sichere Hafen.
Mittlerweile ist es halt ähnlich.
Aber ich glaube, die haben noch nicht das Mimo gekriegt.
Nee, die haben keine Ahnung, keine Idee. Es gibt keine Alternative.
Du meinst, die haben das schon verstanden? Also auch die Politik hat das schon verstanden. Ja.
Ich glaube schon.
Oh. Aber das heißt doch, dass wir eine Marktlücke haben, die wir mal eben ausnutzen könnten, oder?
Genau, deswegen sag ich ja. Jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt halt für eine Alternative. Ich meine, Diskussionen gibt es ja. Also es ist ja schon so, dass...
Und beim Kongress mal zu aufrufen.
Ja, wir werden ein paar Sachen dazu haben, glaube ich. Also es gibt ja durchaus Leute wie zum Beispiel Paul Mason, der halt ein bisschen strukturierter darüber nachdenkt. Es gibt halt irgendwie so die Sachen von so einem älteren Autoren wie Mischkin zum Beispiel, der ja einen großen Einfluss darauf hat, oftet wat die Kurden da gerade machen in ihren Gebieten. Das ist auch eine sehr interessante Sache.
Oh ja, erzähl das doch mal. Das war eine absolut abgefallene Geschichte. So ein alter Kommunist, irgendwie Philosoph.
Nö, nicht Kommunist, eher so anarcho-libertärer Philosoph.
Ein völlig unbekanter Einsiedler irgendwo in der Wüste, war das nicht so?
Naja, nee, nicht unbekanter Einsiedler. Der hat halt in Amiland gelebt, war halt jetzt irgendwie einer von vielen...
Ja, aber nicht irgendwie keine herausragende Persönlichkeit bekannt oder so?
Nee, also nicht eine bekannte Persönlichkeit, ob das herausragend war.
Und den haben sie halt ausgeklappt und haben seine Thesen einfach umgesetzt, man.
Naja, es war halt ein lustiger Zufall. War halt so, dass der Anführer der PKK, der Erdscherlan sitzt ja auf dieser türkischen Gefängnisinsel, seitdem die Israelister abgeliefert haben. Und der liest halt den ganzen Tag, kann halt nicht viel mehr tun und hat irgendwie relativ eingeschränkte Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten. Und dann fielen dem halt irgendwie aus irgendeinem Zufall offenbar die Werke von diesen Mischkernen in die Hand. Und der macht halt so eine Bottom-up demokratische Struktur, demokratische Wirtschaftsstruktur, sustainable. Also sozusagen so, wie man halt so eine Utopie heutzutage eigentlich haben wollen würde, hat er halt irgendwie, beschreibt er halt. Er hat sich auch entwickelt. Also seine Bücher sind halt durchaus unterschiedlich, haben unterschiedlichen Fokus und teilweise ein bisschen mehr anderen, so wie Philosophen halt so sind.
Hatte Öcalan nicht sogar auf seine Insel eingeladen mal irgendwann?
Er hat es versucht, ja, aber das war halt schon zu krank und ist dann halt irgendwie gestorben. Aber jedenfalls, die Dekoden, was die halt da ja machen gerade, ist das im Westen halt fast nicht bekannt. Die versuchen halt in ihren Gebieten also Stabilität dadurch zu schaffen und Stabilität gewinnt nun mal gerade in solchen instabilen Umgebungen, dass sie eben quasi eine demokratische Struktur von unten machen mit einer hohen lokalen Autonomität. Also wo sie sagen, okay, die lokalen Leute wissen am besten, was gut für sie ist, zumindest auf dem lokalen Level, wir wollen den da nicht reinregieren und die bauen dann von unten auf quasi diese Struktur der Ressourcenverteilung und so auf. Und das ist halt das, was sie auch umsetzen, soweit sie sich verfolgen, das ist halt ein bisschen schwierig, weil es halt sehr wenige engesprachige Quellen dazu gibt, nach allem, was man so lesen kann, ist es zumindest in der, also in seiner Weise sind die meisten Quellen auf Reddit dazu.
So faszinierter Anhänger von dem Bildschirm.
Nee, da gibt es auch Kritiker. Also Leute, die da hinfahren und sagen, ja, in der Theorie ist das ja halt ganz schön, aber in der Praxis irgendwie hat es dann doch so seine Grenzen oder Probleme. Ist ja immer so, klar. Aber zumindest versuchen die halt zu sagen, okay, wir machen jetzt hier nicht irgendwie einen Stehlinz-Zuschnitt-Kader-System, wie man es halt von der PKK erwarten würde, sondern bauen halt so eine demokratische Bottom-up-Struktur mit 50% Frauenquote in den Entscheidungsstrukturen und irgendwie ökonomischer Autonomie und Beteiligung von allen und soziale Gerechtigkeit und so weiter von unten halt auf und sagen halt, okay, hier ist ja nix. Also in so einem Irak oder so in Syrien ist ja nix, was noch an Strukturen da ist, außer halt okay, vielleicht ein paar Leute, die halt wichtig sind, von denen man weiß, dass sie halt irgendwie für die zu wichtigen Familien gehören. Paar zerbombte Straßen gibt es noch, die integrieren sie dann halt und versuchen halt auf die Art und Weise eine stabile Gesellschaft zu schaffen, die in möglichst kleinen Einheiten funktioniert, weil sie ja nie wissen, wann ihnen wieder ein Gebiet wegerobert oder weggebombt wird. Und das ist halt so eine der wenigen Utopien, die gerade versucht wird, also auch in der Praxis versucht wird, die für mich zumindest interessant klingen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es wirklich funktionieren wird und ob wir am Ende halt irgendwie, das ist was, was sie halt wirklich im großen Maßstab einsetzen und ob dann doch wieder irgendein Machtwille gewinnt, aber zumindest versuchen sie es mal.
Aber das wäre eine Utopie, die für uns passen könnte, wenn die da erfolgreich haben.
Also was man so hört, funktionieren die da auf dem Lande ganz gut und in den Städten halt nur so mittelgut, weil da das Problem ist, dass die Siedlungseinheit statt zu groß ist für die Entscheidungseinheit. Und wo ziehst du halt die Grenze, wenn du die Grenze halt arbitriert ziehst. Also hier endet jetzt dieser eine.
Da gibt es wieder Streit.
Dann gibt es halt wieder Streit. Das ist halt so eines der Probleme, wo sie halt im Moment so ein bisschen am Rudern sind. Auf dem Land funktioniert es wohl aber ganz gut. Na gut. Aber halt so eine Utopien halt mal zu probieren, also sich auch anzugucken und doch insbesondere vor dem Hintergrund, dass wir uns nun langsam wirklich mal darauf einstellen müssen, dass dieser Planet ein bisschen ungemütlicher wird durch den Klimawandel und wir halt vielleicht mit zentralistisch gemanagten Demokratien da nur so mäßig gut drauf reagieren können. Es scheint mir doch irgendwie der einzig sinnvolle Weg zu sein, von diesem fremdenfeindlichen Nationalismus deine Alternative zu aufzubauen.
Wobei unser System in den Städten ja auch nicht funktioniert und wir auch Schreitigkeiten an den Sektorgrenzen haben. Und wer jetzt wozu gehört, das ist ja in Berlin auch so eine...
Ja gut, die werden noch nicht ausgetragen.
Ja nein, aber gut, das liegt auch daran, dass wir einfach keine Bewaffnung der Bevölkerung haben im Allgemeinen. Na gut, also was mir jedenfalls bei TTIP noch mal wichtig war ist, stellt euch mal vor, es gibt irgendwie Asbest 2.0, irgendein Material, was überall verbaut ist, stellt sich als krebserregend heraus, dann ist, wenn wir TTIP und Schiedsgerichte haben, die Möglichkeit vom Tisch das einfach zu verbieten. Weil das ein wirtschaftlicher Schaden für den Hersteller von diesem Asbest 2.0 wäre und der könnte sich dann vor den Regierungen Milliarden erstreiten. Ja, übrigens, Asbest, ich meine, viele haben das gar nicht so auf dem Radar, aber es gibt ganz lustige alte Werbung aus Zeitungsanzeigen für Asbest, weil das ja ein Feature war. Das ist ja verbaut worden, um feuerresistent zu sein, unter anderem im World Trade Center. Und es gibt eine Werbung für Asbest mit dem World Trade Center. Guck mal, wie toll das da funktioniert. Also rückblickend nicht ganz unironisch. Aber ich will sagen, es gab also Leute, die mit Asbest richtig Kohle gemacht haben. Und wenn es damals sowas wie TTIP und Schiedsgerichte gegeben hätte, dann hätten wir immer noch überall in Neubauten Asbest und nicht nur in den alten Scheißgebäuden.
Na aber wie funktioniert das? Wie stellen die sich das denn vor? Da müssen sie doch vor Gehörungen für getroffen haben. Wenn sich jetzt rausstellt, dass ein Produkt nachweislich schädlich ist.
Also die Idee, glaube ich, wie die Politik sich das vorstellt, ist, dass sie da wieder so kalter Krieg mäßig rangehen und sagen, das wird sich wahrscheinlich rausmitteln zwischen den USA und der EU, wer jetzt der Benachteiligte und wer der Vorteilshaber ist. Und dann gehen dann zwar irgendwelche Firmen den Bach runter, aber die Politik denkt an der Stelle, glaube ich, ihren Volkswirtschaften und sagt, unterm Strich glauben wir, dass die Amis mehr Schmu haben als wir. Und wir, glaube ich, die Merlten malen sich aus, dass sie da unterm Strich einen Gewinn davontragen können, wenn jetzt einfach dieser Weg offen ist. Und es gab sogar einen Artikel, von dem ich nicht weiß, wie viel Wahrheit daran steckt, der behauptet hat, dass diese ganze Idee mit den Schiedsgerichten, die überhaupt in Titebrein zu tun, auf Merkels Mist gewachsen ist. Weil es gibt nämlich schon alle möglichen Schiedsgerichte in der Welt, aber Deutschland ist bisher nur als angeklagter Vertreten und kriegt immer wieder irgendwelche Milliardendinger reingedrückt. Völlig zu Unrecht, wie natürlich unsere Politik findet an der Stelle. Und die Idee bei TTIP und CITA war jetzt, dass wir dann auch mal auf der Nehmerseite sein können von diesen Gerichtsverfahren. So nach dem Motto, wir sind eh schon betroffen. Das wäre natürlich ziemlich krass, weil das natürlich auch unsere Angreifbarkeit deutlich erhöht an der Stelle. Aber so die Idee, dass man im Nachhinein die Wissensbasis sich ändert und man herausfindet, dieses Material hinten wir nie verbauen dürfen oder das ist irgendwie giftig und macht Krebs, das ist glaube ich so einfach nicht vorgesehen bei TTIP.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Das Problem ist, du kannst halt nicht reingucken und es selber herausfinden, weil das alles geheim ist. Aber so von den Regeln, die man bisher sehen kann.
Und also auch in den geleakten Teilen ist dazu nichts zu sehen gewesen?
Nee. Spannenderweise ist im Moment schon klar, dass sowas auch nachträglich nur dann eingebaut werden kann in den Vertrag, wenn alle Parteien übereinstimmen. Und das kann man natürlich vergessen an der Stelle, weil ja eine immer der Geschädigte ist, und der andere immer der, der die Kohle raustragen will. Und es gibt auch keine Klausel, um aus TTIP wieder auszutreten.
Das?
Ja, normalerweise hat man ja in Verträgen, hier die EU zum Beispiel hat irgendwie eine Klausel, was passiert, wenn Großbritannien wieder austreten will. Das gibt es bei TTIP nicht, ist nicht vorgesehen. Also natürlich kann man trotzdem einfach sagen, Scheiß drauf. Aber man hat sich halt vertraglich an diese Schiedsgerichte gebunden. Und die können dann sagen, der Austritt ist aber ein wirtschaftlicher Nachteil für uns. Das heißt, im Grunde geht die Handlungsfreiheit der Politik und die demokratischen Grundaspekte unserer Gesellschaft flöten, wenn wir diese Art von Schiedsgericht haben. Und das ist auch die Hauptkritik an TTIP und CETA.
Das heißt also, dass der Status quo, was Produkt-Sicherheit angeht, quasi eingefroren wurde?
Es wird festgenagelt, ja.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie so doof sind.
Nee, ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass sie sagen, na ja, dann sind wir uns halt einig, wenn es einen wirklich klaren Fall gibt. Ich sag mal, eine Drohne, die wenn sie abstürzt eine Atomexplosion macht, dann würde man halt sagen, okay, da sind wir uns einig und sagen beide, irgendwie diese Samsung-Akkus sind ab jetzt verboten.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Okay, und da wäre man sich halt einig und könnte noch eine Klausel nachbauen, aber diese Einigkeit sehe ich halt in der Praxis nicht, weil das kann man jetzt schon sehen, wie die Verhandlung hat ja schon keinerlei Einigkeiten, das ist total seit Jahren.
Ja, stimmt.
Also, dass die sich dann bei irgendeinem Punkt in der Praxis nachträglich einigen können, halte ich für weitgehend ausgeschlossen.
Na gut.
So, wie lange haben wir denn jetzt eigentlich schon geredet?
Jetzt haben wir hier schon zweieinhalb Stunden auf der Uhr. Na, ich glaube, wir machen mal Schluss.
Ich glaube auch. Schöner Abschluss.
Ja.
Außerdem müssen wir uns noch auf den Kongress vorbereiten.
Genau, wir haben ja noch so ein kleines Kongress-Dingens.
Der ist zwar immer voll, aber wenn ihr da noch nie wart, können wir ja trotzdem mal vorsichtig dazu aufrufen, dass ihr auf Zuliste kommt.
Ja, es wird voll und es wird wahrscheinlich so sein, dass auch keiner...
Aber wir rufen nicht so oft, dass ihr euch die Streams anguckt, denn die werden wieder im Internet sein.
Genau, wenn ihr kein Ticket kriegt, dann guckt euch die Streams an, die werden auf jeden Fall super. Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Falls ihr Lust habt, es gibt da noch irgendwo so einen Flatter-Button, glaube ich, und Patreon haben wir auch.
Und wenn euch das Konzept des Stammtisch-Runde als Sendung gefällt, dann könnt ihr uns das auch mal sagen. Oder wenn es euch nicht gefällt, damit wir so ein bisschen Feedback haben, ob wir das normal machen wollen oder nicht. Oder lieber monothematische Sendung.
Bisher haben wir immer so ein bisschen Abwechseln zwischen monothematischen und Rot-Umschloss-Sendungen gemacht.
Am Anfang haben wir immer so Potpourri-Sendungen gehabt. Und dann sind wir irgendwann übergegangen zu Sondersendungen. Und dann haben wir nur noch Sondersendungen gemacht. Vielleicht sollten wir wieder mehr Potpourri machen. Dann gibt es auch häufiger Sendungen.
Ja, das stimmt. Tatsächlich ist es mit der Beschaffung von Gästen nicht immer so einfach. Die sind dann noch gerade hinter einem Gast hinterher, von dem wir hoffen, dass wir mit dem dann über das schöne Thema Head Speech reden können.
Und wenn das nicht klappt, dann packen wir das einfach so aus.
Dann müssen wir einfach so über Head Speech reden. Aber das wäre vielleicht weniger lustig. Na gut, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.